- What do you want for Christmas?
You could have five pounds or
a Bible. (cash register dings)
The first person chose the five pounds.
(Joey laughs)
The second person asked
for the five pounds.
The third person, they chose the Bible.
And when they opened the Bible up,
there was 10 pounds in it.
(cash register dinging)
- This is the story that gets
people to discover Christ.
(all laugh)
- It's like, "Oh, Lord!"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
(mellow music)
- Hello and welcome to "Trash
Taste" season two guys.
Woo!
- Yay!
- Look at this, new sets. Hello.
- You like?
- Yes, hello and-
- You don't get a say,
that's our set from now on.
- Yes, welcome back to
"Trash Taste" season two.
I'm your host for today, Garnt,
and joining me, once again, are the boys.
I say this, because we've had
like a three week break or something.
- No, no, no. It's longer than that.
- It's like five week break. (laughs)
- Is it five?
- We haven't recorded a
podcast in like five weeks.
- Oh my god.
'Cause you guys have had the privilege of
seeing our faces every week,
but we have not talked on camera
for a good three, five weeks or so, right?
- Yeah.
- I think it's five weeks.
- Yeah, it's-
- How long's it been, Meilyne?
- It must be at least-
- [Meilyne] Since like May 23rd.
- Yeah, a month.
- Yeah so it's at least
four weeks, yeah.
- Yeah, about a month.
And it's taken a long
time to build the set,
a lot longer than I thought
it was going to take.
You guys have seen like the kind of like
rough progression of it from,
hopefully, the "Trash Taste" vlogs
and also the sneak preview
of the sponsorship segments-
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Connor] Oh, right, right.
- Where it's just like a bare
white wall. (Joey laughs)
- It's like, oh wow, great
upgrade these boys are having.
(Garnt laughs)
- I think everything's
changed except for the TV,
the mics and this.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughs)
- Pretty much.
- But we're gonna change the
figures as well at some point.
- Yeah the figures are
eventually gonna be changed
when we can film our figure special.
Unfortunately. Japan's
just about opening up.
So maybe we'll be able to film that soon.
- But we figured, what's
one thing that'll make us
really let people know
that we're based in Japan?
Let's grab some Japanese screens. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs) That's the
most Japanese you can get.
- Oh, are you Japanese? (laughs)
- Oh, you live in Japan?
- It's okay, we have a-
- Show me a screen.
- Japanese guy on it.
So, it's not cultural appropriation.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- I allowed it. (laughs)
- We asked Joey. We were like- (laughs)
- Joey, Joey-
- I was like, did you ask me permission?
- Joey, is this cultural appropriation?
- No.
- I don't know. I don't know.
- It's fine. It's fine.
- The kimono episode. (laughs)
- I gave you the J pass,
it's all right. (laughs)
- Okay, good. Good. Good.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- The J word pass.
- Why do they absorb light
so damn well? (laughs)
- I know.
There's a reason why so
many YouTubers use it.
And I finally understand -
- Yeah.
- Why it's in so many sets. So, yeah.
Hopefully you guys like our brand new set.
- We've got new cameras.
- We just kind of like, got new lights,
we've kind of upgraded
every single aspect-
- Yeah.
- Behind the scenes, as well.
So hopefully it looks clearer to you.
Please don't stare at my pores because
(Joey laughs) I saw
them on our new cameras.
I'm just like, this kind
of makes me uncomfortable.
- Yeah, right.
- 4K pores.
- Now I understand why
movies stars wear makeup on camera.
- God, do I have to start
like fucking moisturizing
and taking care of my face now.
- I already don't like
how I look in 4K, frankly.
- I don't.
- There's a certain Evian water spray
(Garnt laughs)
that you might have to
borrow from Meilyne if
you want some nice skin.
- I do miss the 720p days, webcam,
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- When your face was just
so blurred and smooth.
My god.
- You could see every
fucking pixel on your face.
- Does Aki make you take
care of your skin, face?
I don't know-
- I do skincare routine now.
- Do you?
- I do, now.
- Who got you into it?
- Um. What happened
was, when I was doing 4K
and I was doing streams,
people were commenting
on my skin a lot more.
- Okay, so it is the upgrade to 4K.
- And then, yeah, literally
the upgrade to 4K made-
- Oh, fuck, everyone's gonna be commenting
on our skin now, I swear.
- So then I asked a friend, I was like,
"Hey, I know you're really into skincare."
Obviously a girl.
And they were, I was like
"Hey, you know stuff, right?
Tell me which stuff to use."
(Joey laughs)
They were like, "Say no more.
I've got like 500 Korean products."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Right, right, right.
- I'm like, "Wait, so there's an order?"
- Yeah.
- And I have to do like six things.
- But sometimes I forget.
But it's really long.
I have to put like a face mask on.
And then I use that for like 15 minutes.
- Fuck that.
- Take that off
and then put like three
different lotions on.
- There's a reason why I grow out a beard.
- Yeah.
- It's to hide my pores.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I have really, really bad bags though
and I think that's just very unlucky
and I use like an anti-bag serum
and I swear it just makes my eyes-
- Anti-bag serum?
- It makes my eyes just go
like this, bro, I'm like
(Connor breathes heavily)
(Joey laughs)
- I've got really bad bags as well.
It's genetic, as well.
So it's like, sometimes I
have a good night's sleep.
Great night's sleep. I
go on camera and be like,
"Garnt, are you getting enough sleep?
What's going on there?"
- Oh my god, every fucking time.
- And I'm like, "I'm sorry. I'm sorry."
Mom, Dad, why'd you have
to give me these genes?
- The bags under the eyes is a symbol
of how hard the grind for YouTube is.
(Garnt laughs) That's
what I tell my audience.
I'm like, "I'm on the grind, bro.
- I'm an entrepreneur.
- Sleepless nights, as you can see.
- No, when I do have sleepless nights,
then I look like a fucking zombie.
(Joey laughs)
And then people are just like,
"Oh, this is a fucking
necromancer right here."
But even on my best days, I
still have really bad bags.
- Yeah. I just imagine,
the people who are like,
"Connor, you have bags."
I'm like fuck off.
Like you don't have bags.
- Yeah. Right?
Like you have the most perfect eyes.
- Do you really want me to be perfect?
I don't want to be perfect.
I don't want to have
to deal with that shit.
I'm barely tryna keep my
skincare routine in check.
(Joey laughs)
I'm barely doing anything.
I don't even know if it's doing anything.
- Yeah. That's what I,
I've tried doing a skincare routine.
- Yeah.
- And I stuck on it for a month.
And, I'll be honest,
didn't notice a difference at all.
Or didn't feel too much of a,
maybe felt like a bit of a difference,
but I don't know if it
was like a placebo or not.
- I feel like there are
a lot of businesses made
for our insecurities.
You know what I mean?
(Joey laughs)
- No shit.
- And so, Meilyne came to me,
our producer, you all know,
and was like, "Hey Connor,
do you wanna go to this salon
that my friend owns in Japan?"
- Yeah, right.
- Where they do skincare stuff?"
- All right.
- And then, so I have, like I said before,
I have hemophilia.
So I can't have anything
internal bleeding happen to me.
- Yeah.
- Generally, I think most
people don't want that too.
- No, no, no.
- That's normally like a big
no-no. (laughs) (all laugh)
But I literally can't have
anything that even risks it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And so this, one
of the skincare things
was like "May cause internal bleeding"
and I'm like, "Hold up."
(Joey laughs)
What skincare going on
here is internal bleeding?
- How does something maybe
cause internal bleeding.
- So the first time I
was like "No, no, no"-
- May cause organ failure
but you'll look great.
(Garnt laughs)
- So the first time I was
like, "No, no, no, no, no.
I'm not doing that."
- Yeah.
- And then afterwards they were like,
"You should try it. It's
not really that bad.
It's just the whole medical
thing of it might, you know?"
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, "All right,
fine." Fuck it, I guess what-
- You did it?
- Yeah, I did it.
So what it was, it was like electrocution.
It was like plasma.
As Meilyne laughs, 'cause she's
like, "It's wrong, Connor."
(Joey laughs)
Basically.
- [Meilyne] Plasma shower.
- It was called a plasma shower,
which isn't very comforting.
- That sounds like-
- Right?
- The most horrible punk band-
- Right, so.
- I've ever heard.
- That sounds like an old,
from a League of Legends
character or something like that.
(Connor and Garnt laugh)
- It's literally like an
electric rod or something
that touches your face.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And I think it like strips your skin.
I don't really know what it's doing,
but when it would touch
me in certain places,
my face would go like,
(Joey laughs)
a fuckin' twitch.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- And I could smell-
- It's literally like the
frogs experiment, right?
- Yeah. It smelt like
burning. (Garnt laughs)
And I was like, "What is this?"
- Did you just get tricked into
doing electroshock therapy?
- I think they burned my face
and I paid a hundred bucks for it.
(Joey laughs)
And then they did something
else, which was like,
it was like a vacuum and fluid
and it felt really fuckin' weird.
And it was like-
- Yeah.
- And they were doing it on my face.
It was going in my ear cavities.
- Ugh.
- I'm like, how much is skincare worth it?
(Joey laughs)
- At this point I was
like, I don't think this,
however good my face looks, I
don't think it's worth this.
- Dude. I used to have
horrible acne in high school.
So compared to then, I'm taking
this, I don't give a shit.
- Who didn't? Who didn't have
horrible acne in high school?
- But I had like, mine was so bad that,
did you ever use Proactiv?
- Nah.
- Yeah, kinda-
- It's like that really famous,
anti-acne thing, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That says that if you have acne,
just use that for like a month.
- Yeah.
- You'll be completely clear.
- I did use it. Didn't do shit.
- It didn't do shit for me.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- I was like, it didn't do
shit, so then my parents
were like, "All right. I
found a stronger option."
- Yeah.
- And just tried the stronger options,
nothing fuckin' worked. So I
had to go to the dermatologist
and literally take drugs for it.
- Did it work?
- It worked, it worked. I
mean, now my face is clear now.
So I'm just like, compared to
that, I'll take these pores.
- Fuck I had horrible
acne. I just dealt with it.
- Really?
- And then I was just like-
- What do you mean you just dealt?
Oh, you just let it happen.
- Just left it, yeah.
- Oh, really?
- I mean, I also, I think
working at McDonalds didn't help.
- Well, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, that-
- The deep fat fryer, I swear, dude,
that shit turned my pepperoni
face into like McGigan.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, McDonalds' kitchens-
- Oh my god.
- Are like 95% oil humidity, right?
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- That kicked it into overdrive.
- Yeah.
- I don't know when it
went, but early YouTube,
you can see I had like fucktons of spots.
- Right.
- Luckily-
- You weren't that spotty
when I met you though.
- No, dude. When you watch
this episode go live,
I'm sure Moudan's found a picture
(Joey laughs)
of me looking like, I don't know,
like a puss fuckin' machine.
- I don't know.
I don't think you were that
spotty when I met you either.
- I met you when I was like 21 though.
- Okay.
- So I think, by then,
it started calming down.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, when I was
like 19, it was really bad.
- Yeah, I'm glad I started a YouTube
after all of my acne went away.
'Cause God, I can't imagine.
- I was fat and I had acne.
- 'Cause the thing about
skincare routine, you know,
'cause we all care about optimization
and all that kind of shit, right?
(Joey laughs)
- [Connor] I do. I do.
- There's just something
about going my entire life,
taking five minutes to
get ready in the morning
and then adding a skincare
routine on top of that.
And then you quadrupling
that time in the morning.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Not even quadrupling, you
add like an extra half an hour
to an hour sometimes, per morning.
And I'm just like,
is it worth this time effort
that I'm putting into?
Is it making a difference? I dunno.
- That's the the other reason why
I wanted short hair for a long time,
just 'cause I was just like, dude,
it's like one wipe of the towel
(Garnt laughs)
your hair's dry.
That shit feels so good.
When you get a clean, like a
hair cut and it's quite short
and you just, whoosh, dry hair.
- Yeah.
- You're like, all right, I'm ready.
- I mean, that's why I
decided to get rid of
my really, really long hair
that I had at the
beginning of "Trash Taste".
'Cause some mornings I'll
wake up and I'm like,
"Why is my hair still damp?"
(all laughs)
From the night before.
That doesn't make sense.
- Yeah, now I just have the
bristle. Like five seconds.
- Your hair moisture should
never be part of your routine
that you have to like
put in and be aware of.
- Mm.
- Because that's when I know
I need to get a haircut,
when I started noticing
that my hair's still wet
when I want to do something else.
And I'm just like, well I guess
it's time to get a haircut.
'Cause it's getting way too
much effort to like gel and dry.
And that's why I have a huge respect for
anyone who has long hair and
has to deal with that shit.
And I don't know, how long did
you have your long hair for?
- Way too long. I think I
had it for like six months.
Maybe.
- Six months?
- Yeah. It probably went
down to maybe around here.
- That was during the
"Trash Taste" days, as well.
- [all] Early "Trash Taste" days.
- But yeah, once I cut it, I was like,
"God, why did I ever have that hair?"
It was so horrible to manage it,
especially 'cause I had
it in summer as well.
- Yeah.
- So it was just like a
fucking sauna on my head
and I fucking hated it, yeah.
- Fuck.
- Never again, never again.
People miss it, people are like,
"Oh I want the Jesus hair back."
I'm like, "Yeah, no you don't."
- Fuck off, bro.
- No, you don't.
It's disgusting.
- How did you guys
figure out, kind of like,
when's the first time you figured out
what kind of haircut you wanted?
'Cause I went through like
my entire life as a kid-
- Have they seen your haircut?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. I just
kind of like didn't know.
Obviously. Put up the picture.
I didn't know how to take care of my hair.
- [Joey] The Sasuke haircut?
- [Garnt] Is it obvious?
Is it obvious?
- How the fuck did you
style that shit, man?
- It was, you know what, the reason
I styled my hair like this,
is because it was the hairstyle that took
the least amount of effort to style.
- Fuck off. No-
- Because when my hair was that short,
like my hair is just,
my hair just naturally
spikes up when it's short.
So all I need to do, is get
a bit of gel, put it in.
Whoop, whoop, whoop. And it's done.
- What's the whoop, whoop, whoop? (laughs)
(all laugh)
- I don't know!
(all laughing)
- That's the sound of the
gel mixing with the hair-
- Whoop, whoop.
- It makes like a whoop-
- If you did, you would've
blown up way earlier
if you did a how Gigguk
styles his hair video.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
I'm sayin', you'd have blown
up like a year earlier.
- How to get a Sasuke
haircut in three seconds.
(Joey and Connor laughing)
- It wouldn't have been worth it, 'cause-
- How to get hair that doesn't exist.
- It wouldn't have been worth it because
it would have been a one
minute video. (laughs)
- Exactly.
- Couldn't get the 10
minute ad revenue from that.
- Step one, gel. Step
two, whoop, whoop, whoop.
- You could have a 10
million view short right now
if you did that. Upload
it to Gigguk, right now.
- Maybe I'll make a TikTok.
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- Oh, no.
(Garnt laughs)
Don't do that.
- YouTube short. YouTube short.
- Have you ever thought
about starting a TikTok?
- No.
- No. I'm already burned
out with all the shit I do.
(Joey laughs)
I can't do TikTok.
- I have respect for people
who start TikToks now
and do content creation and
all that shit on the side.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's like I barely have enough time
to fuckin' upload on my main channel.
- Yeah. As a kid, I thought
like, old people, parents,
they just don't know how
to use the new technology,
new social media.
And as I've grown older,
I've realized that's not the case at all.
It's just, we just don't have
the time to get into them
or learn how they work.
- No.
- And that's just the end-all, be-all.
Your parents could probably
use everything you use.
They just don't have the time or energy
to get into something new.
And they'd just rather stick
with something comfortable, right?
- Right. I think I did
open TikTok one time.
And I was gonna make a video on it,
like actually using it.
And I got like five
minutes in and I was like,
"What the fuck is editing?"
I was so confused.
And I was like, "I don't like
this. I'm not used to this.
I'm scared of this."
Maybe that's how boomers feel.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like, "Ahh, what is this?"
- Unfamiliar territory. Delete.
- I mean I could, I'm sure
I could have learned it
if I spared the time, but I
was just like, "Oh, fuck this."
- Is it worth it?
- Cause it took me this
long to just learn fucking
YouTube and Twitter.
(Joey laughs)
And that's like, I feel TikTok's adding
so many extra layers.
- Yeah.
- Which I appreciate when
there's a good TikTok meme.
Because a lot of TikTok I see is shit,
but when you see a good TikTok meme
there's nothing that compares
to the fucking levels of,
I couldn't even explain it.
There's so many levels of just
meme and internet culture,
condensed into such a
short period of time.
- I've probably seen
some of the funniest shit
come from TikTok.
- Oh, 100%
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There was this one, I
don't know if you saw it.
It was about, this guy was
doing a TikTok with his,
he was introducing his girlfriend.
- The Star Wars Day one!
- [Joey And Garnt] Oh, yeah!
- Today's my birthday
and I'm going to introduce
to you my girlfriend.
And then it's literally like
the whole hostage situation.
(Garnt laughing)
So good.
- And then they just add,
an extra layer just keeps
getting added, every time.
And it just goes so far beyond
what you thought it would
that I just think it was fucking genius.
- Oh it's genius, so good.
- When TikTok's like that,
I fucking love TikTok.
- Yeah.
- Everything else, I'm an absolute boomer
when it comes to TikTok.
(Joey laughs)
- Jesus.
- 'Cause what I will say is
that, the content algorithm
on TikTok seems to be so
far beyond other platforms,
where it's so easy to find
content that suits your tastes.
- Mm.
- Whereas, I don't know,
with YouTube now, it's just,
YouTube seems to be going
through a transition period,
where it doesn't really know
what it wants to recommend you.
Should it recommend you
shorts or long videos?
It doesn't know any more
because the internet is
kind of switching around.
- It's also 'cause YouTube's
just tryna compete with
literally every other
social media out there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So when they added like the whole
Instagram Stories replica as well.
- Oh, yeah.
- I don't even know what
those were fuckin' called.
- Yeah.
- They were like. There was that.
And then the Community posts
is literally just Twitter.
- Remember when stories were just Snapchat
and then Instagram had Stories
and then Twitter had stories,
then YouTube has stories.
- Everything has stories now.
- Everything has stories.
- I hate the stories on
Twitter. I hate them.
- The Fleets, you mean?
- The Fleets.
I fucking think they're so garbage.
- I used it once and I was
like, "All right, I hate it."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I'm never using that again.
- I never look at my friends' ones.
- No.
- I never post any.
I'm like, get that shit outta here.
- Yeah.
- It's taking up real estate
on my app. I don't want it.
- Yeah, it's another
shitpost I could be seeing.
- Yeah.
- It's that amount of space
that's covered up by Fleets.
- I feel like, do I really
need my tweets to delete?
I'm not really that into it.
I don't think they need to be deleted.
Just save it for-
- I already have old tweets
delete automatically
from my thing, anyway so.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It makes it completely obsolete.
- Who wants them to be
deleted in 24 hours?
'Cause no one's looking at it anyway.
If it was a tweet that
got deleted in 24 hours,
I could kind of understand
what that would be useful for.
Like if I'm posting, I'm
going live on my Twitch.
- Yeah.
- Delete it in six hours.
- That makes sense.
Why is it in a completely
different section, I don't wanna-
- I don't. (laughs)
- I don't know.
- Yeah. Have you seen the
Twitter live streams as well?
- Well, yeah. And then also
Twitter just copied Clubhouse
with essentially the whole app
and just put it in Twitter,
which I think it actually suits more,
but I don't use it.
- Is that what that is?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I keep getting
notifications of like
certain artists I follow being like-
- Starting a Space or something.
- Yeah, they're starting a Space.
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's just,
I think it's just, again I don't use it.
- I'm just like, "What the fuck is this?"
- I don't know.
- I don't know. I hate it because
I didn't know what it was.
And some people who I like,
I'm a big lurker online, right?
And some people are who I
was following started this,
you know, Space thing.
I joined it and it was like,
"Gigguk has joined the room."
I was like, "Fuck!".
(Joey laughs)
- Get that shit, no,
they don't need to know.
- I hate that.
- Yeah, it's horrible. No
lurking for you. (Garnt laughs)
- I just, I don't know
if I'm the boomer here,
when I just don't like some
of the new features they add,
I can't figure out if
I'm just being unreceptive
to the new thing
or it's actually terrible.
Like I don't know anymore.
- Mm.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause sometimes things-
- Is it me that changed
or is it the children?
(Joey laughs)
- Because sometimes it
turns out to be really good
and I like it.
But then it's just not integrated
well enough in the start
and I'm not really into it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember I was like that
with Instagram Stories, as well,
when it first started. I
was like, what is this?
Deletes in 24 hours?
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- What the fuck's the point
of this? (Garnt laughs)
And now I'm just like, all right,
finna upload to my story, let's go.
- Now I think Stories
are better than posts.
- Yeah, now I think Stories are great.
- But yeah, maybe, I don't know,
maybe I'm just a fucking
boomer, I don't know, whatever.
- Yeah, it's probably the boomer kind of-
- Probably a boomer.
- It's probably a 24
year old boomer thing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- What can I say?
Oh, you know how we, we're
officially boomers now
because we've held a press event.
(Joey laughs)
That's how we know.
- Yeah, we have. With
actual, probably, boomers
that have been on the same stage as us.
(Joey laughs)
- I feel bad calling them boomers.
They're like really
important people. (laughs)
- It's like legitimate government people.
- Oh!
- [Joey] Oh, fucking hell!
- Fuck! Okay.
Yeah. We say boomers, but
actual official, like political,
important people have
been on the stage, right?
- I mean, you can just tell, I mean,
if you guys went on to the FCCJ channel,
which a lot of you guys did,
I think we had like
4,000 people watching us,
when normally I think they have like six.
- Yeah. A lot of the comments
were really confused.
They were like, "What is this?"
"Can somebody explain what happened?"
(Joey laughs)
- I think we were also
really confused as well.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I guess we can
explain what happened.
- Yeah. What is the FCCJ, Connor?
- The Foreign Correspondents
Club of Japan.
- Correct.
- Yes.
- Which I believe is just
essentially the foreign press.
- Yeah.
- And it's like an organization
for the foreign press in Japan.
- Yeah.
- And a guy reached out to us,
who was the interviewer. Called Fred.
And he was like, "Hey guys,
I'm writing an article
about YouTubers in Japan."
Foreign Youtubers, talking
about, like depicting Japan.
And I thought, to be fair,
that's a pretty good article.
'Cause I mean, I feel like
most of the younger generation
are probably getting a lot of
the information about Japan
from us or Chris or you know?
- Yeah.
- I know I got way more of
it from that than the guides,
because most of the guides are like,
"Oh, you should check out the
Kiyomizu-Dero Temple in Kyoto
and then go," you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's super generic, but no,
I want to see someone do
something really fuckin' unique.
- Yeah.
- I mean, he asked us a
question about, you know,
travel guides, right?
And I just, when he
asked me that question,
I just thought, who reads
travel guides anymore?
- No, no.
- Boomers. (laughs)
- Nah. You say that,
but even my parents now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They've gone, they were
like, "Oh, I've watched
this fellow called Abroad in Japan."
- I'm like, "Oh, fuck off."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Oh god, of course you have.
- Damn it.
- Of course you have.
And even a lot of these travel guides
cite people like Abroad in Japan.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is really funny now.
Now it's just, instead of
actually finding their own shit,
like "Chris found this
really fuckin' cool thing.
Go check it out."
(Joey laughs)
You know what I mean?
- Japan YouTuber Chris Broad.
(Connor laughs)
- But, anyway, so he reached out to us
and he showed us the article
and it looked really legit.
And it was gonna be in Number 1 Shimbun-
- Ichiban Shimbun, yeah.
- I think it's called.
- Yeah. A news-
- Which is a paper here in Japan.
- Yeah. And, as we all know,
we all need, we need a bit more
official backing, 'cause
two of us here are verified
on Twitter.
- Fuck off.
- And one isn't.
And the reason I got verified is because
I had submitted the articles
that were written about me
and the interviews that I've done.
But, obviously, someone
here hadn't had any articles
written about him yet.
- But now we've got an article
about "Trash Taste", so.
- I have articles, I
just didn't submit them.
(Garnt laughs)
I submitted my Wikipedia,
which wasn't good enough
for Twitter verification.
- Of course, because, what was it?
The day that you found out
you guys had a Wikipedia,
you uploaded pictures for each other.
- Yeah. We uploaded pictures.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- We spent literally like half
an hour of this "Trash Taste"
recording-
- Because-
just trying to update these guys' Wikis.
- Well, somebody had
made a Wikipedia page.
And it's very meticulous.
And I was very grateful
for it, but I was like,
why didn't they upload a picture?
- Yeah.
- I feel like this is very
easy. Just upload a picture.
- Yeah.
- And then it got removed
anyway because we-
- Yeah, I was like, "They're
legitimate looking pictures."
- They're our pictures. What do you mean?
- Yeah, I mean we added
each other's pictures
and then like less than 12
hours later it was gone.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
And I'm like, what the fuck?
- Fuck the system.
- How do you get a picture
on Twitter, Instagram,
Wikipedia? Fuck.
- And yeah, so they reached out to us.
And he was like, "Hey, do
you wanna come and give a,
record a pseudo-podcast
on this YouTube channel.
- And we checked it out, and
we were like, "Wow." (laughs)
- It's like, some heavy
topics on this channel.
- Yeah, I think the week he sent it
it was something like
"LGBT rights in Japan".
I'm like, well that's
pretty serious stuff.
And then you want us to
come on and just clown
and then ask us about pizza fucking crust?
(Garnt laughs)
But I was like-
- You can tell that the
"Trash Taste" viewers
had invaded the chat,
because we were having this
very official press conference
and then I get asked about
pizza crusts and anime.
- Yeah, literally the first question.
It was like "All right we
got some questions from the
audience right now.
And the first question here is
"Garnt, what do you think
about pizza crust?"" (laughs)
- I just find it funny how just
utterly unprepared they were
for the amount of questions
there were gonna be sent.
Because I remember, the
person running it just came up
with a huge stack of questions.
(Joey laughs)
And the interviewer looked
at this, being like,
"This is more questions than
I've ever seen in my life.
What is going on right now?"
- It was like 20 pieces of paper.
(Garnt laughs)
Just like, here's the questions.
And the guy's like, "What?"
- The fuck? What the fuck?
(Garnt laughs)
It was quiet fun though, I mean it was-
- Yeah.
- A cool experience.
- And we were like, I
remember the guy was like,
"Oh, it's on an official thing,
FCCJ is a professional thing
that does a lot of press
conferences and stuff like that.
But you guys can just come casually.
Because, you know, we're
just gonna do it casually,
like you guys do on the podcast.
And we were like, "We're wearing suits."
- Bet. Bet.
- Bet.
We're wearin' the suits.
- Nah, I mean, there was that
wall of the previous people
that had done FCCJ press conferences,
'cause they've only started
live broadcasting them recently.
If I understand correctly.
But they've been doing them
for like years and years.
Most of them have been private.
And we saw the Dalai Lama on there. I saw-
- Hayao Miyazaki was there.
- Hayao Miyazaki. Did I
see Trump on there as well?
- Trump. Donald Trump.
- Trump was there.
A very young Trump was there.
(Garnt laughs)
Like, fuckin'-
- You said the President
of Thailand had done it?
- Yeah, the ex Prime Minister of Thailand,
I didn't know this, 'cause
I saw a picture there
and I was like, "He looks kinda familiar."
And I was like, "Where
do I recognize him from?"
So I snap it, send the picture
to my mom and she was like,
"Oh that's the ex Prime
Minister of Thailand."
- Jesus.
- So I'm just like, "Fuckin'"-
- So, only the important people frankly.
- "Fuckin' brilliant".
What's going on 'ere?
- And then, imagine that wall
and then the literal
front of the FCCJ building
is this giant billboard that says like,
"Tonight on FCCJ: "Trash Taste"".
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
And it was so fucking weird.
'Cause we should not
belong on this billboard.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think, as well,
the journalist Fred, was like,
"I want it just to be like a
normal "Trash Taste" episode."
And I'm like, "I don't
think we can do a normal"-
- That's not-
- No. No.
- That's not how it works.
- I don't think we can just
turn up here and just do a
normal "Trash", I think I'm
gonna have to be polite."
- Yeah.
- Was he expecting us
to rock up and be like,
"Oi, dickhead. What's going on?"
(all laugh)
- 'Cause I saw a lot of
the comments be like,
"This is the most calmest and most polite
I've ever seen the boys."
Well, yeah.
If you'd seen the stage that we were on
you'd probably act the
same as well, honestly.
- If you knew who was on
this stage before us then you
would probably act like that as well.
- (laughs) I saw a comment
that really made me laugh
and it was like, "The water
man's doing God's work.
Not a glass empty for a single second."
(Joey laughs)
I was so awkward, as well.
'Cause we were just
sittin' there and this guy
just creeps over with water,
like bent over and I'm like,
"Oh, I feel so bad for him."
I'm like, "I don't need water."
- [Joey] I was like, "Why
are you topping me up?
I'm basically full."
- Yeah.
Also, Joey, why did you
have to go to the toilet
mid-sentence?
(Garnt laughs)
You couldn't have waited
until you finished speaking?
- That was hilarious.
- Okay.
I deadass was holding onto
that shit for dear life
for like-
- You could have done it before
you started the sentence.
- For like thirty minutes.
- After you
started the sentence.
- No, I was like, "I'm gonna
go for as long as I can."
And I think about an hour into
it, 'cause it was a two hour,
I think, live thing.
- Yeah, it was two hours.
- About an hour and 10 in,
I was like, "I'm gonna die."
(Garnt laughs)
- My bladder is about to explode.
- Why not before you-
- But I can hold on, it's like 50 minutes,
if I just concentrate on
talking and just listening,
I can get through it.
(Garnt laughs)
- And, I got, I forgot what,
what question did I get?
- You were actually getting asked
a serious question about Japan.
- Yeah, you were in the
middle of a serious question,
and you were just like, "Da-da-da-da.
Sorry can I go to the toilet?"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Didn't even finish your, you just went.
And I was like, "Joey, what the fuck?"
- No.
- I literally got mental whiplash.
'Cause I was like, "Oh, this
is Joey being prim and proper
and professional."
(Joey laughs) Then out of
nowhere, he just busts out the,
"Can I go to the toilet?"
- You can hear the very
moment my heart just snaps,
and I'm just like "You have to go."
(Garnt laughs)
And I was just like, "I'm
gonna cut this sentence short.
I have to fucking go, otherwise
I'm about to piss onstage
in front of 4000 people."
- I'll be honest, when you
asked to go the toilet,
I looked at you and I'm
just like, "Should I do it?"
"Should I do it?"
(Joey laughs)
- I was like, "No. No. Hold! Hold! Hold!"
- I was like, I looked
at you guys and I'm like,
"I can't be the only one
who's busting for a piss."
- Oh.
- Like Garnt should be dying right now.
- I was dying, inside.
My leg was like going
at fuckin' sonic speed.
(Joey laughs)
It was just like, "Come on. Come on."
- That's why I was like,
"Water boy, if you come near me
one more time and fill up that glass.
I'm going to kill you.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't need.
I have stopped drinking water
for the past 30 minutes,
'cause if I drink one more sip of water,
I am going to explode.
Stop filling up my glass."
- You could've just been like,
"Can you hand me the bottle?
Could you hand me?
(Joey laughs)
Just give me the bottle boss man."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I just drink it and then
slowly bring the glass down.
(Garnt laughs)
- "This is gonna be a
really weird question.
But can you get under the table?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Yeah.
- Nah. I couldn't man.
I was like, "Do I just ask the question
or do I piss onstage?"
(Connor laughs)
"Imma ask the question."
(Garnt laughs)
Fuck it.
- He said, he was like,
"Yeah this is the first time
it's ever happened in
the history of the FCCJ"
or something, right?
- I'm like, "Bullshit!"
There's gotta be another
Asian person who has a bladder
just as small as mine.
- Sure. Surely there's
someone else out there
has a small bladder like us.
- I take his word for it, Joey.
I think you made a, you
ruined a press conference.
- Or I made history.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
By being the only person-
- There's a lot of people
who've made history
and it's not this.
- A lot of people have
made history on the FCCJ
but no one's ever taken a piss
break in the middle of one.
- I gotta ask. What did you
guys write in the guest book?
'Cause I remember, so we had
to sign a guest book, right?
So every guest who's been
on there has to sign it
and write some kind of
message or something.
And we had some really like
deep, important messages.
You know, some talking about some very
hot political topics right now.
Some people, I think one message
I saw said something like,
"We must listen to the
voice of the people.
The people will not go unheard.
And there's only so long that
we can stop listening to them."
Or something along those lines.
And then I turn the page
and it's just my message
being like, "(speaks in foreign
language) Gigguk, 2021."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- At least you came up
with a kind of funny one.
I saw that and I was
like, "I can't top that."
- Why? What did you write?
- I think I wrote something
like "I like anime. Yes I do."
Or something.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- What?
- Only the biggest of brains.
- Is that the same thought
process you went through
when you came up with The Anime Man?
- Yeah. Yeah, literally.
- Mr. Worldwide.
- I like anime.
I like anime. Yes I do.
- I like Anime. Yes I do.
Joey "The Anime Man" Bizinger, 2021.
- I just put, "I don't
know what I'm doing here."
It's literally all I wrote.
- I mean, that's probably the most honest.
- That's probably the most honest one
- I was like, "I don't know
what I'm doing here. Connor."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Connor. Not even your
full name. Just Connor.
- No, just Connor.
I was like, "I don't know
what I'm doing here."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Oh man.
- Nah, but it was a great experience.
It was super weird to be
on something that official.
And I don't even think our
fans knew how official it was
when they were watching.
- Well, we didn't even
say anything about it
until ten minutes before.
We were like, "Should we
tweet out that we're doing it?
It's being live-streamed. We may as well."
- And now it's the most
viewed video on their channel,
as well.
- Ayy. Let's go.
- I think, probably by the
time this video is live,
it has well over a half 1,000,000 views.
- I think so, yeah.
- I mean, it's pretty-
- Which is pretty insane.
- I mean, it was basically just
like a "Trash Taste" episode
but just polite.
- Polite.
- Yeah.
- The gentlemen.
- I did like all the
memes which were like,
"Oh damn. POG to the new studio set."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Damn. That's where all the budget went.
- Yeah, that's where all the budget went.
- Yeah, it wasn't a "Trash Taste" episode,
it was the Garbage Taste episode.
(Joey laughs)
- I remember, I saw their
camera and I was like,
"Weak. What a weak
camera." One camera angle?
(Joey laughs)
- One camera angle.
- What is this, a SONY
hand-held? What is this?
Come on, get a real one.
- Manual zoom-in. What is this?
I was like, "Where's the
lights? Where's the lights here?
Come on." Look at this.
(Joey laughs)
- They were like, "This floor
has a restaurant in it."
You guys can afford a restaurant,
but not a good camera?
Seriously? Come on. Come on. Come on.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding,
it was very nice.
- Yeah, we were really
honored to be invited on that
and we realized much, I think
it kinda set in much later.
I was like, "Oh, I think
we actually did something
pretty cool and legit."
- No, I think it's, I don't
know how many YouTubers
can say they've
done something like that.
- No.
- I think we did a good job.
We didn't embarrass ourselves too much.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. I'd say so.
I'd say we were, I mean, we
were way more reserved than
on our usual fuckin'
monkey-mode podcast, whatever.
But, yeah, it was a great experience.
And one of the things we've been doing
in between building the sets, I guess.
- Yeah.
- Among many other things.
- What else have you guys been up to?
- Nothing.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Building this office has
taken so goddamn long.
- Honestly.
- Yeah, it's taken a while.
- You guys will get the full scope of it
in the "After Dark" vlog, which I think,
by the time this goes up might be up?
- Maybe.
We still haven't finished
the "After Dark" set yet.
- Oh yeah, we still gotta
build that too, fuck.
- We're still building the
"After Dark" set but we,
for the first time
ever, I think we're just
one week behind our actual
"Trash Taste" episodes,
which is the closest we've gone
from actually catching up to our backlog.
- I think we've only been like this
at the very beginning of
"Trash Taste", by the way.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
"Trash Taste" episode one, right?
- Yeah, literally, so.
- Well no, actually, I
think, I can't remember,
but I know we always have a buffer
and this is definitely the
closest we've ever gotten
to losing that buffer,
but I mean, the reason
why we have a buffer anyway
is so that if we miss a week
or we need to do something,
it's not a big deal.
And we don't really talk
about current events
a lot of the time.
- Yeah.
- And our audience gets
that whenever we do
talk about current events.
It's very, very outdated
by the time it comes out.
- Like three weeks later.
- Yeah, true, true.
So, E3? I'm joking.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Oh, hi. Didn't see you there. Hi.
It's me, Monke, from "Trash Taste".
I'll be doing the ad reads
for today's episodes.
And this first one is from
a personal favorite of mine.
ExpressVPN!
Watching Netflix while
not using ExpressVPN
is like paying for a gym membership
and only using the treadmill.
It's a waste.
ExpressVPN does a big brain move
and lets you change your
location to anywhere in the world
so that your internet thinks
you're in another country.
And it has over 100 servers in
multiple different countries.
If you're like me and want to watch
other countries' content,
ExpressVPN is perfect for you.
I miss the BBC.
Don't take that out of context.
And I just want to watch
my home TV programming
but sadly you can only watch it in the UK.
But thanks to ExpressVPN,
that's no longer a problem anymore.
And I barely notice that it's always on
and it's super easy to use.
It just takes one click
and you're connected to a server.
And it's seamless.
And it works on my phone, tablet,
fridge probably, and my PC.
And don't forget that it encrypts
all of your data carefully. So
what are you doin'? You know?
You're paying full price
for all these streaming content websites
and you can't get the full library.
Don't forget to use our link down below,
expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
And you shall receive three
months extra for free,
using ExpressVPN.
So don't forget to use our
link, expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
to get three months
for free of ExpressVPN.
Back to the episode.
- Yeah, you had yet another
crazy taxi experience,
didn't you, Connor?
- I did, I did.
(Joey laughs)
I'll send a, oh I wish I
could send you the picture,
of the route I took,
but I'll do a fake drawing of it for this.
'Cause if I show you actually the route,
you'll know where, ah.
- You'll know where
our studio is. (laughs)
- Kinda just doxing where we live.
- You'll know where our studio
is and where I go to school.
(Joey laughs) So I'm not gonna do that.
But, essentially, this guy
took what should have been
a ten minute journey
and did it 45 minutes.
So, what's up with that?
(Joey laughs)
But, I mean. This is the thing, right?
So, what happened was is that,
this wasn't a miscommunication
fault or anything,
because I didn't tell him where to go.
The app tells him where to go.
'Cause I was using a
ride sharing app, right?
So, literally when he
picks me up, he has to say,
"Oh, okay. This is where I pick him up.
This is where I'm going."
And then, when he says he's picked me up,
it will tell him, on
the thing, where to go.
And I got in the car and I saw
where it was telling him
to turn and do all that
and it was where I'd told him to go.
And, for some reason, this
guy just, he ignored the turn.
And I was like, "Okay. Whatever."
He probably knows a better route, right?"
(Joey laughs)
Maybe he knows, 'cause
he was like 80 or 90.
Very, very, very old.
I was like, "He knows the
streets better than the maps,
I'm sure. I'm sure. I'm sure."
And so then he misses the next turning
and I'm like, "All
right. Okay. All right."
Misses the next turning.
And I'm like, "Okay, this
is getting a little weird."
- Must be some local route.
- Yeah, I'm like. And then
he misses another turning.
And this is getting to the point
where I'm like, "All right.
This man is just straight
up going the wrong way."
So I ask him, in terrible
Japanese, I'm like,
"Where are you going?"
And he said somewhere in Roppongi,
which is totally not where I was going.
And I was like, "Oh."
- Literally the opposite.
- The opposite way of where I was going.
And I'm like, "No, no,
no. Don't go that way.
Go the other way."
And then he was like, "What?
What? Where do you wanna go?"
And I told him.
- "I can't hear you, what?"
- I told him where I wanted
to go and he was like, "What?"
And I show him the app and he was like,
"Oh, let me put my glasses on."
I'm like, "You're driving
without your glasses on?"
(Joey laughs)
You can't read this and you're driving?
I'm like, "They do this every time."
Every time I, (grunts).
This annoys me to death
about Taxi drivers here.
Every time I show them
on my phone where to go,
they have to put glasses on.
And I'm like, "If you can't read."
- Why are you driving?
- Why are you driving
without these glasses on?
What is this, blurs? Or is this like Ozu?
Tryna like? What are you doing?
- And no wonder you can't see
the fuckin' navigation system.
- So, yeah. He completely
goes the wrong way
and I eventually get to figure out,
to explain to him where I wanna go.
And it was just 'cause
there was some weird thing
with the address that I put in,
where it wasn't quite what I said it was.
But even though the address in
the thing was still correct.
But I had to then reconfirm to him
that I was going to the place
where it told him to go.
Which is like, why do you even ask me?
Don't talk me. Just take
me where I wanna go.
- Are you sure you wanna go
to the place you specified?
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- This is what I don't get.
I told you where I wanna go.
"Maybe you can confirm?"
and I said, "Yes."
What? What?
I'm losing my mind, right?
So the thing is racking
up to be pretty expensive.
'Cause this is like a 45 minute journey.
It's pretty fuckin' expensive.
- Yeah.
- Especially in Tokyo, as well.
- Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause you know, the
journey I was gonna take
was just 10 minutes and
it was supposed to be
like 10, 15 bucks.
Not a big deal.
It turned into like a 45, $50 ride.
And I'm like, "Hold the fuck up."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
And also, after I eventually
told him where to go,
I was pretty stressed
out, I was like, "Argh."
And I was trying to watch YouTube videos
and I was looking at my phone
and then suddenly, the
guys just emergency stops.
So, my fuckin' bag goes flying,
my water bottle goes flying.
I'm like, "Yo, what the fuck?"
(Garnt laughs)
- This is like the best bit! (laughs)
- (laughs) And yeah.
I was like, "Listen, I don't
if you're going for the
worst taxi speedrun any% here.
(Joey laughs) I don't
know what you're tryna do.
You are literally fucking
everything up here."
- He's deadass like a "GTA" player.
- Yeah. He nearly crashed the taxi.
And it was unfortunate
'cause I couldn't see
if it was his fault or not.
It looked like it wasn't his fault.
So I didn't blame him that.
But it was also just kind of annoying.
- Man's just out here
playing "Crazy Taxi".
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah he was literally
playing "Crazy Taxi", bro.
And then, immediately, okay,
after this, as well, I think
because he was panicked,
because he'd taken me wildly off route,
he'd nearly crashed the car.
- He wildly fucked up.
- He pretty much fucked up everything
a taxi driver could fuck up.
So he started speeding
(Joey laughs)
to get me to where I needed to go.
And I did not feel comfortable
with this man speeding
after he just nearly
crashed the fuckin' taxi.
(Garnt laughs) So I was like,
I asked him, I asked him,
"Can you go a little," in Japanese,
"Can you go a little slower?"
And then he panically
turned his full head around.
"No, no, no, no, no, no."
- Hold on, I gotta put my glasses on
to check the speedometer. (laughs)
- Normally, I normally am
fully accepting of the,
that kind of turn.
"Oh, yeah. Okay, got you, got you".
He was like, "Wait, what did you say?"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
I'm like, "No, no, no."
He's going like 80 on a 50 road.
I'm like, "Stop. No, no, no."
I'm not gonna say anything,
I'm not gonna say anything.
And then, I was like, "This
is the worst fucking taxi ride
of my goddamn life."
And so, every taxi driver
in Japan has their full
company information and name
and everything on the thing.
So I took a picture of
it and my phone has the,
in Japan every phone has to make a noise
when you take a picture, it shutters.
There is a ch-ch.
So my phone did that.
So I think he heard it, I don't know.
So anyway, he finally
got to me where I was.
One piece. I had to check myself
when I got out of the car.
Am I alive? Right.
And as I was getting out, he
slowly pulls his wallet out.
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, "Are you tryna bribe me?"
(Connor and Joey laugh)
To not complain.
- Is that even legal?
- I don't know if it's legal.
- Probably not legal.
- Probably not.
- Probably not. I think so.
He didn't tell me, "Don't say anything."
I think he was tryna pay the difference,
of what he went over.
'Cause it worked out to be
around what he went over.
So the fee should've been like $15.
It was like 40.
So he gave me like 30 bucks.
And I was like, "Fine."
You know what, I don't want
to complain to your company.
(Joey laughs) I don't
want to have to do that.
'Cause I wanted to get my
money back from the company,
'cause I was like, "This
is fuckin' terrible."
I don't know if that's me being a Karen.
I just think that I don't
want to get ripped off
and I was like-
- No. I mean-
- I don't think it's a Karen to be like,
"I almost died. Can I have money back?"
- 'Cause I, dude, I hate, I do not,
I will never ever complain
about someone who is doing a job
where you don't make much money.
'Cause I'm just like, I don't feel like-
- No, I get it.
- I don't think you get
paid enough to warrant
you losing some money.
You know, if I have problems
at fast food places,
I'll never, I'll just be like,
"You know what? It wasn't
great. I'll keep it to myself."
I'll deal with it.
I might leave not a great review.
But I won't be super harsh.
- You're not gonna be like,
"Where's the manager?"
- That's the British way to do things.
- I just, again I don't
want to make someone's life
more difficult than it is,
life is fuckin' hard enough as it is.
But, there is a certain
point where I'm like,
"You have done such an awful
job where I think it's okay
for me to want my money back."
- Well yeah, of course. Of course.
- I feel like taxi's understandable.
'Cause your life is in their
hands, as well. (coughs)
- And literally, everything was terrible.
So I was just gonna complain to the,
not to his company first, I
was gonna complain to the app,
to see if I, 'cause the
app can normally just,
'cause he'll still get paid, I believe,
and then they'll just refund me.
Which is what I wanted.
Because fuck the
multi-conglomerate company.
- But instead, he just took out
the middle-man and was like,
"Here."
- Yeah, instead
he paid me 30 bucks.
And I was like, "Sure."
So I gave him five stars.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- He's like, "I don't speak any English.
But you speak this language, right?"
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I think so.
- "You know what I'm sayin'.
You know what I'm sayin'."
- I was like, "You know
what? The man's hustling.
All right. Fine. Fine. Fine."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Literally bribed a five
star Uber review from you.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I was like, "You know what?
The man knew he fucked up big time
and he wanted to try and fix it.
I respect it. I'm down."
I don't wanna go through this.
You don't wanna go through this.
Let's just walk away from this happening.
- You don't speak Japanese,
but you speak the ones and zeroes.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Well, 'cause all I wanted
was the difference back.
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm happy to pay the taxi fee.
I just don't wanna be
charged like 30, $40 extra
when I don't need to be.
I'm not like a fuckin',
I'm not a cheap guy.
- I get that.
- I just don't wanna be ripped off.
- I feel like taxi drivers
here are very aware of that.
Because most people in Japan,
especially in the service industry,
are fuckin' super nice.
- They don't rip you off.
They don't rip you off.
- They do not rip you off
at all, 'cause I remember,
I had to take a pretty long
taxi that went via the highway,
but there was really bad
traffic there on that day.
And so, it took like, I think
like 20 minutes longer than
they journey shoulda taken.
And the taxi driver, he
told me that he was gonna
stop the meter early because he feels bad
that they were stuck
in traffic for so long.
Even though they went via the highway.
So I'm just like, "Damn, man that's"-
- That's not even his fault.
- Yeah, that's not even your fault.
You're a real one, man. You're a real one.
- Yeah, when you taxi,
you're just gamble, man.
'Cause maybe the highways are congested,
that's the risk you take.
- That's just part of the risk.
And I feel like just
taxi drivers, or anyone,
it's so weird to me that
you can't tip people here.
'Cause out of every country
that I've lived in and been to,
the one country I've wanted
to tip people the most
is here in Japan.
And it's just, it feels bad
because I've gotten some of
the best service I ever have
anywhere in the world.
And I can't pay them a bit
more to show my appreciation.
- I think the only service
in Japan that you can
actually tip people is Uber Eats.
But that's just because
it's integrated in the app.
- But that's just 'cause it's Uber.
- Yeah Uber Eats is Uber, right?
- Uber Eats, which is an
international company, right?
- I always tip if it's raining. (laughs)
- Yeah, I always do, yeah. 100%. 100%.
- I feel so bad for them when I order food
when it's raining.
They turn up at the door
fuckin' soaked. I'm like.
- Especially when it's
typhoon season as well.
(Connor and Joey laugh)
You're just like, "Damn, man."
- I'm like, "$3 okay?"
(all laugh)
- "$3 for your troubles, sir."
Oh my god.
- Yeah, I don't know. It's just, oh fuck.
It was such an awful
experience, it was just like.
And I felt so bad, 'cause I was in,
I was tryna optimize
it, so I ordered food,
like lunch, to arrive at the studio.
For when I was gonna get
there and then I was like,
"Joey, can you get my Uber Eats?"
- No, 'cause I was waiting at the studio
and Connor was like, "Yeah
I'm 10 minutes away."
And I was like, "Cool."
I'll see him very soon then.
Like 30 minutes pass, and
I'm like, "Where is he?"
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- Yeah I saw that on the message stream.
'Cause I wasn't there
at the studio that day.
And I was like, "Why
is Connor telling Joey
to get his food?"
- Can you get my food?
- This white boy getting
more privileged every day.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- "Joey, I don't wanna deal
with the Uber Eats man,
please get my."
(all laugh)
- "I can't speak Japanese,
can you get my food for me?"
(all laugh)
"You're the (speaks in foreign language)
Joey, so you can do it."
- Jesus Christ, man. Fuck.
- That's why I'm always
scared, man, to get on taxis.
'Cause it's like, again, in Japan,
85% of the time, they're
over the age of 70.
And I just don't know what to expect.
Sometimes they're the
most pristine, proper,
fuckin' Batman's assistant
levels of amazing driving.
But then, sometimes you get
people like that, right?
Where it's like, you shouldn't
be behind a steering wheel.
- Yeah, I had a guy one time.
I got in the car. Started
speaking fluent English to me.
And I was like, "Wow."
(Garnt laughs)
- Really? (laughs)
- "Wow." He's like, "Are you
comfortable with the AC?"
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, "What?
What did you just say?"
- In like a really velvety voice? (laughs)
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
The man sounded like PSY,
from "Gangnam Style".
(Joey laughs)
- Was he old?
- Nah. No, he looked like 30.
And I was like, "Wow. Wow. Wow."
- Well that's like an extra
star point, right there.
- What are you doin' being a taxi driver?
- Yeah, I was so confused.
I was just so caught off-guard by it.
I was like, "Yeah. Yeah. It's
great. It's great. Wow. Wow."
'Cause normally they don't
ask you anything in Japan.
- Normally if someone's
below the age of 60,
you rarely see someone below
the age of 60 be a taxi driver,
especially here in Japan.
- Oh. I'll just give you a life hack
for if you ever come
to Japan and use taxis.
They're only ever gonna
ask you two things.
Where you're going.
And do you want to use the highway?
And that'll always be the second question.
Just say yes. Just always say yes.
Don't say no.
(Joey laughs)
Okay, so once you've told them
where you're going, right?
Even if you don't understand
what the fuck they're saying, right?
So once they've figured
out where you're going,
about like five minutes into your drive,
they'll turn around and ask you something.
And just say yes.
(Garnt laughs)
'Cause they're gonna ask
you about the highway.
- That's just a Japan
life hack, in general.
If I don't understand what
someone's saying, I just say,
(speaks in foreign language).
(Joey speaks in foreign language)
- Just say, (speaks in foreign language).
You'll remember this. If you
come to Japan, remember this.
He's gonna ask you
something two minutes in,
five minutes into the taxi drive.
He's gonna be in the middle
of driving. Just say yes.
He's asking if you
wanna go on the highway.
Just say yes.
- Someone probably could've
asked me if I could be
like an accomplice in a murder
and I've said yes to it, in Japan.
(Joey laughs)
Probably don't know.
'Cause I've just said yes to everything.
The only time I know, I
actually have to pay attention,
is when there's like, "What,
are you sure about that?
Did you know, did you just
press agree on terms and conditions?
Do you know what you just agreed to?"
(all laugh)
- And they do like a
fuckin' "Millionaire" thing,
they're like, "Final answer?"
(Garnt laughs) "Final answer?
Are you sure it's a yes?"
And I'm like, "Oh, oh, oh,
can you repeat that?" Oh shit.
And then even when they repeat that,
I'm just like, "Yeah?"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- 'Cause on the signs in
Japan, on the highways,
it just says "Expressway".
So I just assumed, they
call it expressway too.
But it's not called expressway.
- No.
- They call it, what is it?
(speaks in foreign language)
(Joey, Connor and Garnt
speak in foreign language)
(Joey speaks in foreign language)
(Connor speaks in foreign language)
- Yeah. That's what I said.
- Which is direct translation
for "High, fast road."
(laughs)
- Ah, well.
- So there you go.
- But I was also told that
they understand "highway".
But I was confused, so
I never said "Highway",
'cause it always says "Expressway."
So I never said highway.
But they'll understand if you say highway.
- Yeah, highway, yeah.
- Second life hack.
If you don't know a Japanese word,
say it in (speaks in foreign
language), then- (laughs)
- Yeah, really.
- And then-
- It'll feel racist, but it's not.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah, so if you don't
know, if you can't read
(speaks in foreign
language), just say it in the
most racist Japanese
accent you can think of
and they will maybe
understand you, sometimes.
- Yeah dude, sometimes,
when I'm streaming in it
and I have to say a word
like that, people Pepe laugh,
"Connor just said it a funny accent."
I'm like, "No. That-
- That's literally
how they say it.
- They won't understand
unless I do that.
- I love how all these
people, yeah, because
everyday words have just become
more and more English now, right?
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause say, like "Spicy",
right? Do you want spicy food?
It's like, "No, the
Japanese word for it is
(speaks in foreign language)."
- [Garnt] I've always said that.
- You can also just say spicy.
- Oh. Oh, you can?
- Oh, you can?
- Well, I like that. I didn't know that.
- And it's the exact same thing.
- Didn't know that.
- Like "sexy"? It's just "sexy."
(all laugh)
"Milk"? It's just "milk."
- Yeah, 'cause I learnt, what was it?
A recent Japanese word, oh cafe.
Which is like (speaks in foreign language)
- Yeah, (speaks in foreign language).
- (speaks in foreign language)
is the proper Japanese word.
Or you can just say coffee.
- But everyone just says
cafe here. (laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause your grandma will say
(speaks in foreign language).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My grandma will say (speaks
in foreign language)
but everyone else will just say coffee.
(Garnt laughs)
Everything's becoming English, man.
- Yeah, so I've realized, actually,
in the place that I am now,
it's more easier just
to say yes to everything
if you don't fully understand it.
'Cause I remember me and Connor
had another taxi experience.
- Oh, no! This guy fucking-
- Which was-
- drove me up the wall.
(Garnt laughs)
- Which was on my birthday night.
So after we hung out we
went back to Meilyne's
and we went back to my house pretty late.
And we all live in the same area
so me and Connor got a taxi back.
And we were, this was at like 5:00 AM,
we were very drunk and very tired
and so, Connor orders a taxi via DiDi,
which is kinda like Uber.
So the address is already
in the taxi, right?
- Again, he knows where we're going.
- He knows where we're going.
- It literally tells
him a pinpoint location
where to go and how to get there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we get in the taxi and he asks us,
"Oh, where do you want to go?"
So I didn't know that he
already had the address
'cause he did already have the address
and it was in his system,
so I tell him, "Please go
to this address," right?
- Oh, I think you said
the station near our house
and I think that's when he got confused.
'Cause then now he's like-
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Now he's like, "Wait is it
the station or the address?"
And bear in mind, they're literally
two minutes away from each other,
so I'm like, "Just go there
and it'll be all right, buddy."
Both of the addresses are
in the exact same place.
Just go there.
And so I think then he
started getting really like,
he's like, "Wait, which one though?"
And then every five minutes,
this man would turn around
and ask, "Which one are going?"
Like, "Here? Here? Here?"
And we were like, "Yes. Yes."
- And I was trying to explain to him,
"It's near the station.
It's near the station." Right, right?
And he's just like, "But
it's a different address,
Where do you want me to go?"
And I was like, "Just go to the,"
my Japanese wasn't good enough to say
"Go to this exact address."
I was just like, "Just go near the station
and we'll direct you."
And he was like, (heavy breathing)
"Am I going the right way? Am I?" (laughs)
- Do these taxi drivers
not have freedom of choice?
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- It's literally the same road.
It's not even remotely far.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's like a computer
tryna run two programs
at the same time.
It's like, "Which one do I
open first? I don't know."
- I literally gave, he was like an AI
and I just gave him a logic bomb.
(Joey laughs)
That's how he acted and I was just like,
and I just thought to myself,
this is not on the taxi driver,
'cause obviously it was
just a language barrier,
but I just thought to myself,
"I should've just said
(speaks in foreign language)."
- (laughs) I should've just said yes.
And just said, "Yes,
please go to the address."
- You didn't use the life hack, man.
- Also, we did say (speaks
in foreign language)
like seven times in a row.
And then he still did keep
asking and I was like-
- Yeah because he probably asked,
"Do you want to go the station?"
You're like (speaks in foreign language).
"Or did you want to go to the house?"
(speaks in foreign language)
(Garnt laughs)
It's like, (heavy breathing)
"Which one though?"
(Garnt laughs)
- We used the life hack, but.
- But also, everything we said to him,
he was clearly, he was quite old
and his hearing was clearly not great,
'cause everything we said
we had to repeat but louder.
And I feel like some things
we said pretty fuckin' loud.
He didn't understand. And
I was like, "I'm done."
- Or maybe that was just your,
maybe in your guys'
drunk mind you were like,
(speaks in foreign language).
But it reality it was like, (gibberish).
- I was very, very sober at this point
'cause I was just tryna sleep.
And he kept waking us up, and I was like,
"I'm fightin' for my life
just to get five minutes
of sleep here, buddy."
- Sydney was sitting next to me.
She doesn't remember any of it.
She was passed the fuck out.
- Oh my god. This is like,
Sydney kept making it worse.
'Cause Sydney was drunk and kept going
(speaks in foreign
language), saying things.
(Garnt laughs)
And we were like, "Sydney
shut up. Literally shut up.
You're confusing the man."
(Garnt laughs)
- (laughs) I completely forgot.
- She literally kept making it worse.
I was literally about to be like,
"Garnt, tell her to shut,
get Sydney to shut up,
I swear to God."
'Cause she was clearly not even awake
and she'd be like, (speaks
in foreign language).
And we're like, "We're not
even there. Not even there."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
She would say like, "Oh, here's fine."
Or like, "Keep going."
And we're like nowhere near.
And she'd be like, "Here's fine."
No. Sydney, Sydney,
Sydney. Please. Please.
- (laughs) She was dream
Japanese talking in her sleep.
- Yeah, yeah, it was,
I was like, "No! No!"
- I found it impressive,
'cause it was like she
was speaking Japanese
that was off enough that it made no sense
in the context that we were in.
But it made enough sense that
someone would say it in a
taxi, right? So. (laughs)
- All the correct things
you would say in a taxi.
- I remember, I'd keep
going like, "Sydney, no.
Please. Please, Sydney.
Please stop. Sydney, stop."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Oh my god.
- Yeah but we eventually
got home after what,
it felt like, two hours.
- So wait, did he drop
you off at the station
or you house?
- Yeah he did, he did.
He dropped us off at the station.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- I was just like,
- He finally came up with it.
- I didn't even want to try
to direct him to my house.
Just stop. Just let me
out. Let me out, bro.
- Fair enough.
- Let me out.
Get me out of here.
I can't stand this.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, but I mean, that's
part of the reason why
we're looking to move, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Have we talked about how
we are looking to move?
'Cause we've-
- Yeah you've talked about
moving, right?
- I've moved already,
yeah, a month ago now, at this rate.
- I'm currently in the process of,
I've applied for a
place, just hoping I get,
I mean, I find out this week,
so just praying I get it.
- I think doing the whole
moving process again
has reminded me how much
of a nightmare it was
the first time, to get a place here.
And I just didn't
realize, or I'd forgotten,
because I had everything set up.
And now I'm going through the
process again, I'm just like,
"Damn, it was a nightmare."
And I'd completely forgotten about it.
- Yeah.
- It's equal parts exciting
and equal parts just dread.
- So far, it's not been too bad.
It's been really annoying being rejected
for really petty reasons.
- Yeah.
- That's been quite annoying.
But that's, I feel like
I'm so used to that now,
where I'm like, "I'm not
the right nationality?
All right, cool. See ya."
(Joey laughs)
Fist bump. "Later, dude."
So I'm kinda used to it but, yeah.
- I mean, how many places
have you been rejected from
so far, just one, right?
- Ah, two, two, two.
- Oh, two.
- But some of them were not rejections
'cause I didn't apply but
some of them were like,
"Oh no, no. No foreigners."
- Ah, just straight up?
- So is that like a
rejection? Do you count that?
- No, that's a rejection, I'd say.
- 'Cause that's like, I feel like-
- That's like 10, 15 then, right?
- Half of them are gone.
Half of the whole Japanese housing market
is just unavailable to me.
- I'd say it's like even more than half.
Even if you have the money
to pay for this house,
you just can't get it,
for whatever reason
- I think we talked about this.
- We've talked about
this a lot. Yeah, yeah.
- Episode two or something,
where were talking about how
it's fuckin' impossible for
foreigners to rent in Japan.
- It's also, I feel like this
happens everywhere though,
you have to kind of like
decide what's important to you
and you have to make sacrifices
depending on, you know?
Even if you have unlimited
budget, there's not gonna be,
if you wanna get a house in certain areas,
it's just not possible in Central Tokyo.
- Oh, yeah. I mean, unless you're actually
buying the property, you
don't have to do that, right?
- The thing is, when I'm
looking at houses now,
the first question I ask is,
"Has anyone else applied for this yet?"
And if the answer's yes, I'm just like,
"Well, that's pretty
much my chances gone."
(Joey laughs)
- Soa didn't tell me this,
but if someone asks to apply,
the odds of you getting it are super low.
'Cause it's normally just
first come, first served.
And if the person before you is Japanese,
they're probably not gonna get rejected
unless they're like super sketch.
So if, yeah, like you said,
they took me to see places
and half of them would
already been applied for
and I'm like, "What am I doing here?"
(Garnt laughs)
What, so you can and of
course, the two places-
- Check out this place
you probably won't get.
- So the first place they took
me to visit was five houses
and the two that I really, really liked,
of course, were the two
that had applications.
So I was like, "Great. So
now I've fallen in love
with two places and I
can't fuckin' have them."
- (laughs) It's like a literal cock-tease.
- It is! It is.
- So now you've shown
me what my standards are
and you've taken them away from me.
- It's like, "This is what you could have
if you had a Japanese passport."
(all laugh)
- And so then, I was like,
"Okay, well I don't like the other three,
and so can we find new ones?"
We found new ones,
didn't like any of them.
And I was like, "Well this sucks.
'Cause now I don't like any
of these fucking things."
And eventually, found a
few that I kinda liked
and I've applied for
one, that I quite like.
Maybe neighbors might be
an issue, we'll find out,
but I'm just gonna soundproof the room
before I move anything in.
- Well again, that's a sacrifice
you have to take, really.
It's pretty fuckin' hard.
I mean, I think the one-
- I'm gonna have neighbors, yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
The one sacrifice I took with my place is
it's just slightly kind of out of the way,
especially when you go into Tokyo.
But everything else is, fuckin' love it.
- It's a great house.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm just
planning to put soundproof panels
on the wall, and I'm just gonna
put that on the side walls
and the roof and the carpet.
- Yeah, you got your first
noise complaint, didn't you?
- I did get a noise complaint, yeah.
- After all this time.
- I know. I was definitely
pushing, to be fair.
I think 'cause when I first moved in,
I wouldn't even walk at
full speed around the house.
'Cause I'd heard how careful I had to be.
And then I realized,
oh, nothing's happening.
Oh, so I start walking normally, you know?
- So you kept testing the limit.
- Slowly keep pushing that.
- And then the "Apex" stream
starts getting later and later.
- The "Apex" at 2:00 AM streams did the,
pushed it over the limit.
- I don't know what it was that did it.
Because when I go the complaint,
I hadn't done any late night streams
that I would say were loud.
I'd only done one and it
was a very, very quiet one.
I know it was, 'cause
I was actually talking.
I wonder what did it, 'cause
there was some where I was
full-on shouting at 2:00 AM.
And I didn't get it. So I don't know.
- I mean, we go a noise
complaint at our place.
But a week-
- It was the speedrun.
- Yeah, but a week after the
actual event that had happened.
So I'm just like, "Why am I
getting the complaint now,
after a week?"
- I think 'cause it goes to the agency
and then the agency tells you, right?
- But the agency has my
number on speed dial.
So they could easily have just
called me the next morning
and been like, "Ah were
you loud last night?"
- Yeah, they could have been
like, "We've got a snitch, bro.
It's kinda cringe."
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- No, no, because I
was so confused, right.
- "We got you, bro. Don't worry about it"
- No, legit, I was like, "Who said it?"
(Garnt laughs)
"Who?" I was literally like
Liam Neeson from "Taken".
I'm like, "Who sent you?"
- Well, they won't tell you.
I understand, privacy reasons.
But also, I'd like to know so that
I can kind of maybe put
some stuff on that wall.
- Right, right. 'Cause
if I know who it is,
at least tell me, 'cause they
didn't even tell if it was
someone from the same building.
- "Tell me who's a little bitch
so I can soundproof that sound."
- No, because if I knew it was, say,
the neighbors downstairs,
then I could be like,
"Oh, okay. Maybe I should do
some padding on the floor."
Or something like that.
- Get a thick-ass carpet.
- Or a thick-ass carpet
or something to avoid it.
Or if it's people across the
road, well then it's like,
well I can't do fucking
anything about that.
So, I guess.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh my god.
- Meilyne, just say hi.
- Meilyne, what is this,
the FCCJ?
- Go on, go on, go on Meilyne.
You've gotta be water-
- Gotta shake his (indistinct).
- Water boy.
If I knew who the
neighbor was then I could
take precautions and work so
that I don't have to do it.
- I always understand that
if it was me complaining
I probably wouldn't want
to be named but also,
you could maybe-
- I don't need to know
the specific person.
I just need to know is
it a neighbor below me?
Is it someone across the road?
Is it in this building? I don't know.
- I guess they're worried
that you might go to him
and be like, "Yo. Open the fuck,
why you complaining, little bitch?
(Joey laughs) Why you
complaining? Why you such a-"
- "Say it to my face, motherfucker!"
- But then also, you could be like,
"Hey man, can I ask you when
you need me to be quiet?"
You know, is there stuff goin, 'cause
if my neighbors, dude, they can shout
all they fuckin' want.
I don't give a fuck.
But if I was, if I had a kid or something,
then maybe I'd be like, "Hey,
keep it down after 10:00.
Shout in the day. I don't give a fuck."
- That's the problem,
'cause if that was me,
and I was getting noise complaints
from, say, someone from upstairs,
I'd just fucking go up
to them and be like,
"Hey, I'm not gonna snitch
on you or something,
can we just talk it
out so that we can come
to some kind of mutual agreement?"
But, in Japan, no one fuckin' does that.
They're just like, "Ring,
ring. Help me please."
- But I asked, I asked,
like "What can they do?
What can they do with this complaint?
What happens?"
They were like.
- They can technically get you evicted,
if they tried really freaking hard.
Especially if you're a foreigner.
'Cause I mean, from my last place,
that woman downstairs tried to do that.
- I'm like, "How-"
- Until I (speaks in foreign
language) her. (laughs)
- I'm like, "How fuckin'
hard to do they have to try
to get me evicted, then?"
Is it like, "How much effort
do they have to go through?"
And I think they said
"A lot of work and it
probably wouldn't happen."
So I'm just like, "Well.
I'm not that bad."
I'm not shouting all the time.
I have turned my volume
down during streams.
- At least you're not doing
construction at like 2:00 AM.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't think they'll
kick you out or anything.
- Just fuckin' get the
drill out, you know?
- Like "Shawshank"-
- Who's gonna complain now?
(imitates drilling)
- "Shawshank Redemption" in this shit,
waiting for the lightening to strike.
(imitates hammering)
But, I think I've done like,
they clearly don't care during the day,
'cause I've done voice
lines during the day
where I'm full on screaming.
Like full on.
No they don't care during
the day. It's only at night.
- I bet some neighbors
do care during the day.
They're like-
- I mean, I think-
- The pompous neighbors,
they're like, "Oh, god,
I'm uncomfortable at 2:00 PM."
- Maybe on the week-
- "YouTuber? What is that?
Voice actor?
God, I just thought someone
was getting murdered up there."
- The agent, who was finding
me my apartment was like,
"I watched your YouTube."
I didn't tell her my YouTube.
But they had to know my company.
- Yeah, yeah. Of course.
- Oh, okay.
- And so I think she just
went on the company's site,
saw my name, she watched
my YouTube videos."
I was like, "Oh, God."
- You just got "Are You YouTuber"-ed.
- "Are You YouTuber?"
- Yeah, I was like, "Oh, cool.
Which one did you watch?"
And she was like, "Oh I
watched you drinking alcohol."
And I was like, with
Chris, and I was like,
"Oh my God."
- Of all the videos.
(Garnt laughs)
- What a terrible introduction to me.
- This is what I do for a
job. I get sloshed on camera.
- Gonna think I'm a serial-
- So this was, you filmed
this in your house?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was like, "So do you film
all the videos in your house?"
I'm like, "Ahhh."
(Joey laughs)
I'm like, "It's very
rarely. It's very rarely."
- I got a studio, you know.
- You know, I film a lot
outside. Rarely film indoors.
You know, honestly, I'm
barely talking, frankly.
- No, that's how I got my place.
I literally had to tell the
people who I was applying it to,
they were like-
- You can't tell them anything.
- Yeah, 'cause they, the
person who owns my place
watched my YouTube, 'cause
they had to know as well,
'cause I was applying under my company.
So they were like, "So are all
your videos filmed inside?"
I'm just like, "No, no, no.
Most of these are outside."
And they were like, "Okay. Okay. Okay."
- To be fair, I never record
past like, 5, 6:00 PM.
It's just streams.
Which again, I mean, it's
not much better, but.
- I remember, you said before, in London,
you used to record like 2:00 AM or 3:00AM.
- My neighbors didn't give a fuck though.
But, then again, they
were blasting "Peppa Pig"
through the wall at 2:00
AM, so I don't really.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- "Pepper Pig".
- What kid is watching
"Peppa Pig" at 2:00 AM?
- It's like, "Mom, put on the
episode. This one's a banger.
Turn it up, Mom, turn it up."
- Turn it up.
- I don't know if it's like-
- It's my favorite OP.
- I don't if it was 'cause I
was in a kinda not great area
of London, I don't if there's like
a mutual understanding of like
"No complaints. No police. No police."
Because my neighbors had like
10 people living in a house
that had like two bedrooms.
So I dunno know how much
police they wanted over there.
That's why, I'm pretty sure,
they never ever said anything.
'Cause one time, multiple times actually,
I opened the door to
get a package from them
and it looked like, you know,
just like so many fucking
people were living in there.
It was crazy.
I was like, "Ooh. See ya."
It was very weird.
So, I think that's why
they never complained.
And also, the walls are
thicker. That's what I-
- Have you ever had a neighbor from hell?
Or like a bad neighbor?
Japan aside?
- In England?
- No. I've been pretty good.
I think you did, you
mentioned in on "Trash Taste".
- Did I?
- The really loud sex, yeah.
- Oh, no, not that. That
was actually a fine-
- Oh, that was pleasurable? (laughs)
- That was a fine-
- I enjoyed hearing their
sex through the wall.
- That was a fine neighbor.
- That's my homie, right there. (laughs)
- We high fived.
- We had a mutual understanding.
They could have sex in the next room
and I could record
podcasts whenever I want
and be a YouTuber.
(Joey laughs)
It was great. They didn't complain at all.
And I didn't complain, in turn.
- But did you have a neighbor from hell?
- Yeah, I did actually.
- I never do, fingers crossed.
_ Yeah, it was the actually the place
I had moved to after that.
So it was actually the first
place I moved into with Sydney.
And we just had this guy living above us.
And we didn't know this when we moved in,
but we moved into this house
that was basically like a HMO,
so a house of multi-occupancy,
which is like basically a
house that has been like-
- Cut up.
- It's been cut up to have
several people living in it
So the walls, we didn't realize
how thin the walls were, right?
And we had a guy living above us that,
he was old, he was an older gentleman,
and definitely had few
screws loose, right?
'Cause he said that he used
to work for the police, right?
And he would bring this up constantly
because in this house that we were in,
they had heavy fire doors, right?
So we'd have to really be super careful
when we were closing the doors.
There's letting the doors go,
but there's also like,
because these doors were so heavy,
sometimes you'd just have to yank it in.
And sometimes that yank
was just a little bit
too much power behind it
and it would just make a loudish noise.
And so this guy living above us, he was,
at the beginning he tried
to be a nice neighbor
and we tried to be nice neighbors as well.
And then we soon came to realize that
this guy had massive anger issues.
I'm pretty sure,
one day he could be the nicest guy ever
and the next day he would just blow up
for the smallest reasons
and we were just like,
"Yo, we kinda don't feel safe."
Every time we'd maybe shut
the door a bit too loudly,
at first he'd tell us, right?
Be like, "Please shut
the door a bit quieter."
And we're like, "Sorry. That was our bad."
We knew about it.
And so we'd be extra, extra careful.
But, you know, when you
go in and out your house
pretty often, right?
And sometimes you just yank it a bit loud,
a bit more harder than you would, sorry,
sometimes you yank it a bit
harder than you intended to.
So one time, he told
us to be careful, fine.
Nothing happened for a month.
And then, at around 7:00
PM, I just yanked it
and I was like, "Oh, shit.
That was a bit loud."
Literally comes downstairs, fuckin'
(heavy footsteps thumping)
"What the fuck did I tell you?"
- Jesus Christ.
- He literally full on fucking screamed,
I'm like, "Yo, what the fuck is going on?"
And from that moment on,
keep in mind this was a
month after the last time
I'd accidentally shut it a bit too loudly.
I was like, "Yo, Sydney,
I'm thinking we're living
below a crazy guy here."
- Well, at 7:00 PM, who gives a fuck?
- Yeah, and it was 7:00 PM, as well.
It wasn't even in the dead of night.
- "What the fuck did I tell
you a month ago?" (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Jesus.
- And so, I don't do the Japanese thing,
I go up to him and knock
on his door and like,
"Yo, bro, let's talk it out. Come on.
Let's come to an understanding here."
And so we talk it out and he's
very polite and very calm.
(laughs)
- Well, fuck.
- That's how they get you man.
- He's very calm about it, right?
And we're just like, "Look. Look, mate.
This is the first place we've moved to,
with my new girlfriend."
And he was saying
just, "Sometimes walls are
very thin, so just keep in mind
that I'm right below you."
And I'm like, "No, I totally get it.
After 10:00 PM, that's
when we're super quiet.
We'd normally go to sleep,
'cause I gotta work the next day as well.
But you know, sometimes we're
not even talking at a loud
kind of volume or whatever, so
as long as you can understand
that we are a couple and we talk,
as people do when someone
else's in the house,
then we'll try to keep
it down at late hours."
Cool.
And so I go back downstairs,
literally a week later.
Not even closing the door this time.
I'm literally just having a
normal volumed conversation
with Sydney and instead of shouting,
he starts walking around really loudly.
Starts smashing down
on the floor.
(footsteps thundering)
Like this, right?
We're like, "What the fuck is going on?"
Me and Sydney, we're like,
"What the fuck is going on?"
So I go back upstairs and I'm like,
"Is everything okay?
Are you having a stroke, a heart attack?
What's going on?"
And he's like, "Look.
You're being fucking loud
and I just wanted to
teach you a lesson, right?
This is what you get for speaking loudly."
I'm just like, "What
the fuck is going on?"
And this has literally
scarred me for life, right?
Because I was living in fear that this guy
was gonna do something.
'Cause over time, 'cause we lived here
for a year and a half,
and obviously our relationship
deteriorated. (laughs)
As it would when I've
felt in fucking danger
living in my own house
and Sydney felt in danger
living in our house, as well.
And so it got to the point where
some days we'd just be talking
and he'd just randomly start banging
on his fridge doors or his cupboard doors,
making a lot of noise when he thought that
we were making a lot of noise.
And we were just talking
and having a normal
conversation most of the time.
- [Connor] What the fuck?
- And eventually it went from
the, the relationship went
from me trying to talk it out with him,
to being like, "Dude, what
the fuck is your issue?"
And he's like, "Bra, I
used to work in the police.
Don't fuck with me, man.
If I wanted, I'd call them over.
I'd get all my mates,
I'd get the boys over
and I'd get you out.
Just say the word.
Just don't fuck with me."
And I'm just like, "Fuck.
Sydney, we gotta move
out as soon as possible."
This was one of the big
reasons why we moved out
and so on the last night
where we moved out,
Sydney was already gone
'cause she had gone back home
to America, so it was just
me and a mate talking.
And so it was me and a mate talking
and we were watching a movie,
so we weren't even talking,
it was just the volume of
the TV at that point, right?
And we get this bang on
the fuckin' door, right?
And this guy starts screaming, full volume
in my face, right?
He's just like, "I know
you're about to fucking leave.
And I'm fuckin', I'm glad
you're about to fuckin' leave
but I need to give you one last
piece of my mind. Fuck you.
You've been the worst fucking
neighbor of my entire life."
- Jesus.
- And then he starts going off
about how he's part of the police again.
I'm like, "Bro, calm the fuck down."
At this point, this is
probably the most pissed off
I've been in my life.
And I'm like, "Dude."
- Monkman went out the window.
- No, no, no, no. I'm just
like, "Dude, back the fuck off."
And then he looks at me, right?
He looks at me straight in the eye.
And he's like, "Go on. Have
a swipe. Have a swipe."
(Joey laughs) "Go on. Go on."
- Jesus.
- 'Cause I knew he wanted
me to throw a punch
so he had a reason to call the police.
- [Joey] Of course, of course.
- And I straight up tell him,
I straight up look him
in the eye and tell him
"Dude, you don't know who
you're dealing with here.
I was a fuckin' monk,
I'm not gonna punch you."
(all laugh)
I'm like, "I'm fuckin'
zen right now, dude.
You can try as hard as you
like, I'm not gonna punch you."
And he gets closer and he's
like, "Go on. It's easy. Go on."
I'm like, "Dude, just back
the fuck off now please.
I'm gonna re-enter my home,
please just fuck off."
- He's so sad. What a sad guy.
- And that was the last I heard of him.
And that was my neighbor from hell.
I really hope that no one ever
goes through that because-
- How did you, how did you stay in there
for a year and a half, dude?
- 'Cause our contract.
- Oh, yeah, right.
- Literally, it was hell
because anytime that we wanted,
and we hated being in
that house, eventually.
After about six months to a year,
we just stayed at my parents
house as much as we could.
And then eventually we just
straight up just moved back
to our parents' house.
Because it was like a fuckin'
hell living in that house.
And that's kinda why I never want to,
that's why I hate apartment sharing now,
because that one experience
has taught me just,
I just want my own space.
I want no one to,
like a noise complaint
actually triggers me now,
so I'm just like, "Ohh. Fuck that."
- Oh, dude. I don't fuckin'
blame you after that.
Jesus Christ.
- And yeah, I'd completely
forgotten about that
until we started talking about neighbors.
- Well, there you go.
- Wow.
- Digging up old traumas.
(Garnt laughs)
Only on "Trash Taste".
- Wow, what an asshole.
- Yeah, right? What a cunt. Jesus Christ.
- I'm sure he's happy.
I'm sure he's happy.
- I'm sure he's happy now.
- I'm sure, yeah I'm sure
he's happy now.
- No, I think the early
signs were there because-
- I'm sure that he won't
get a neighbor who's
better than you, anyway.
- Yeah, right?
- I'm sure he's probably
dealing with people who are-
- Yean, no, 'cause there were
early signs that were there.
Because he was telling me
about the dude that lived
in that place before was
also a "young person" as well
and he would not stop complaining
about how much noise he made
and how loudly he shut the door.
I'm just like, "I mean, I've
shut the door. It's loud.
But it's not like fuckin'
shake the house loud."
- I'd probably just get to
the point where I'd just start
making noise to piss him off.
He can swing and smack
on my door all day, man,
I've got the SONY WX thingies,
I'm noise-canceled, bro.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- It's what noise-canceling
headphones were made for.
- Sure, what are you gonna
do, break into my house?
Fuck off.
- What's this apartment
made out of, paper?
- I think so, man. I dunno. I don't know.
- Jesus.
- 'Cause what, in the UK, what is it, like
10:00 PM is the official time
where you're not allowed to make noise?
Yeah, so right before 10:00 PM,
I'd probably just blast music non-stop
and then when 10:00 PM hits, turn it off.
(Joey laughs)
And then rinse and repeat.
- Yeah, what's the worst they can do?
Because I was just trying
to be a nice neighbor.
- If it's before a certain time,
and I think the noise pollution
is below a certain decibel,
I think they can't do anything.
They actually, I don't
think they can do anything.
- Like legally, they can't do anything.
- I don't think so.
I could be wrong on that.
I don't think they can.
As long as it's within
a reasonable amount.
- Yeah.
- So it's just the arsehole
tax that you pay them?
- Yeah.
- Okay. Okay.
- Well you can just start
ignoring him, right?
(Garnt laughs) Maybe
he'll take a swing at you.
- Maybe. Maybe, you know
what I shoulda done,
just gotten some nice
noise-canceling headphones.
- Yeah, you should've bro.
I mean, just, if he knocks
on the door, who cares, bro?
(Garnt laughs)
Sleep through it.
What's he gonna do? Break down your door?
Like nah, bro.
(Garnt laughs)
- Just Kool-Aid Man's
here, "You're too loud!"
- And then you can call
the police. (laughs)
You can see his friends. If he has any.
- I can see the boys, I can see the boys.
- If he actually has any.
- That he's talking about, right?
- This your mans? This
your mans, right here?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- People who brag about
that kinda stuff normally
don't have as strong ties
as they make it out to be.
- No, they don't, no.
- Oh, I mean, I feel like he was an ex-cop
for a reason, right?
- (laughs) He's not a current cop.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, fuck.
Yeah, I've never really
had bad housemates,
I've just had housemates
that didn't pay bills.
But there's ways of being
able to get them to pay bills.
- Yeah, I think that's why-
- I mean I would argue a housemate
that doesn't pay the bill
is a bad housemate. (laughs)
- Yeah. I would argue that as well.
- Would you? I'd rather,
because, right, what we
would, what I would do,
because I was in charge of the internet,
and I was the only one,
'cause these guys, I
mean they were my age,
but they didn't, they weren't very-
- Knowledgeable?
- About like, yeah, about
technology and internet stuff.
- Right.
- And they didn't realize
that if you had the password
to the internet you could log in
and turn off the internet
to certain devices.
- Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did you know you could do that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
So you can just type in the, what is it?
Whatever the numbers are,
the 19, whatever 182,
and then you can log in.
- The IP address?
- Yeah, the IP address, you'd log into it
and you could just turn off
devices, so I would just,
if they didn't pay me,
I would just turn off
all their internet for all their devices.
(Joey laughs)
- And then I would-
- That's literally
the equivalent of your mom
taking your Switch away
'cause you didn't do your chores.
It's like, "Until you do your chores.
No more playtime for you."
- Yeah, and then they would be like,
"Oh, Connor, I've got an assignment."
And I'm like, "Why didn't you pay me?"
"Pay me and I'll put your
internet back on." And you-
- That's a power move, dude.
- Well, yeah, 'cause I'm like,
"They're not gonna pay me."
'Cause they were being
assholes, so I was like, "Well."
- No, rightfully deserved, yeah.
- "You haven't paid for
me like half a month now,
we're all students, I don't have money."
This is, you know, I'm paying
a bill for four people,
you can't pay me like 10 quid, come on?
- Of course.
- Well, that's why I
hated being in charge of,
when you're in university,
were you the guy,
I'm guessing you were the guy
in charge of paying the rent, then?
Or was it just-
- Ah, so the rent was
actually done separately.
But the bills were done through me.
And it was only in the second
house that I had a problem.
The last house, there
was only three of us,
they were all really chill
and they all paid, whenever I asked.
But the house before that,
they just never paid.
'Cause they were just
spending it all on weed.
- (laughs) As they do. As they do.
- As they do.
- Yeah, yeah, so I was like,
"Well, I mean, all right, well fuck."
- Yeah 'cause you always have
one housemate in uni that just
was never there and
never paid for anything
and you'd have to fucking
hire a private investigator
or something to get this guy's money
or get the money from that guy.
- It was weird, man, 'cause
one of my housemates,
he was like, what, how old
are you in second year?
Like 20? Barely 20, 19?
- 21, maybe, 20, yeah.
- He had a, his girlfriend was pregnant
and then he had the baby, and
it was just all so surreal,
when I'm here, barely
have my life in order
and this man just brings his
fuckin' child into the room.
And I'm like, and then I'm like,
"What goin' on, this is so weird.
I don't like this."
(Joey laughs)
And then I felt bad
asking for internet money.
I'm like, "Hey, by the way,
can you pay the bills?"
- "I know you have to
feed your kid, but, ah."
- I'm like, "I'm sure you
can go a week without weed,
just pay me, bro.
And give your kid some
Starburst or something,
I don't know."
(all laugh)
"Just pay me, I don't know."
- "I've got some top ramen left over,
you can give it to your baby."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And also, I think his girlfriend
basically lived at our house
and I was like, "Should
she be paying some bills?
I don't know?"
- I mean, to be fair-
- Is it weird?
- You should, but.
- I was like,
"I'm not gonna ask but I think you should
just pay me on time.
And we've got no problem.
I don't give a shit."
So annoying,
'cause it just wouldn't
get done, unless I did it.
- Yeah, of course.
- We wouldn't have internet.
And I'm like, "Well, I want internet.
So I'm gonna do it.
(Joey laughs)
I'm gonna set it up.
Oh, and inadvertently
it's in my name, fuck."
- Well maybe it was better though,
that it was inadvertently
in your name, right?
- Yeah, well 'cause then I
canceled it all, I did it.
And all that.
And I think one time they didn't pay me,
for the last month, and because they left,
they just straight up refused to pay me.
This video is sponsored by Mack Weldon.
Kick your summer off
in style with the brand
that's reinventing men's
basics, Mack Weldon.
Mack Weldon is so much
more than just underwear.
I'm wearing the pants right now.
There's t-shirts, polos, masks
card cases, I believe, and many more.
All the material is light and breathable.
It's super comfortable for any occasion.
And right now, in the summer, I need that.
So whatever you're doing,
Mack Weldon's essentials
has you covered.
And they've just brought out the new
Mack Weldon swim line
that are quick to dry and have
four-way stretched fabric.
When you're not in the pool,
Mack Weldon's new
Maverick Tech Chino Shorts
and Radius Short are the perfect additions
to your summer wardrobe.
They'll keep you comfortable
so you can confidently power
through your most active days.
Mack Weldon also has
a free loyalty program
called Weldon Blue.
Level One gets you free shipping for life,
once you reach Level Two by spending $200,
you get 20% off every
order for the next year.
Stay cool this summer and look good
while you're doing it,
with the new Mack Weldon's essentials.
For 20% off your order,
visit mackweldon.com/trashtraste
and enter the promo code TRASHTASTE.
That's mackweldon.com/trashtraste,
promo code TRASHTASTE for 20% off.
Mack Weldon, reinventing men's basics.
Back to the episode.
We just went for a pee break.
(all laugh)
As I was saying, right before we left,
that house, the one where
they didn't pay the bills,
they actually owed us, I
think it was something like
80 pounds in the end, in overdue bills.
And because we'd all left the house,
I couldn't hound them,
I messaged them on Facebook
and they wouldn't send it to
us. And so, I had to pay it
and it was actually me and my friend,
we were the only ones who paid bills
and we were really,
we were really close and
I still hang out with him,
still message him sometimes.
Really good friends with him.
And we both basically paid all our bills
and sorted it all out
and yeah, so we had to then
pay the bills for two months,
for the other guys who didn't pay.
We were really annoyed about it
'cause we were trying to get them to pay
and they weren't paying us.
And then, I felt like some
cosmic justice was given because-
- The gods smiled down on you.
- The gods were like, "Hold up, Connor."
So it turns out, right, we'd
actually overpaid our bills
and then we got a rebate,
so they'd actually given us money back,
which was actually more
than what we actually owed.
So we ended up, given like 50 pounds back.
And my friend was like,
"Should we give it
equally between us all?"
I'm like, "Do you think they
would have done the same?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I'm like, "Let's just split it 50-50."
- It's like, "How about, fuck 'em."
- It's 25 quid. Let's just keep it.
Let's just go to the
pub. 'Cause fuck this.
- Hell yeah, dude.
- They weren't gonna pay us. (laughs)
- I bet if you messaged
them, they would've replied
at the speed of light.
- Probs.
- They'd have been like,
"Here's my PayPal, by the way."
(all laugh)
- "Oh hi, I'm just gonna send you money."
"Oh, yo. No worries. No
worries, come at me, fam."
- Pub? Pub? Pub?
- You know, I do feel a
little bit bad about it,
even before we record, I'm
like "Can I tell this story?"
- Oh, fuck that, dude.
- "It's like me,
am I stealing here?"
- I would've done
the exact same thing.
- They would've done the exact same thing.
I wouldn't have been sorry about it.
- Especially if they
didn't pay you, as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, they literally
wouldn't reply to our messages
about paying us back.
- Ah, fuck that.
- I felt bad, but I was also like,
'cause I'd just would never
ever steal, but I was like-
- If they're not gonna follow the rules,
then why should you
follow the rules, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, I agree.
- I feel it's fair.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- Yeah, I feel like
going through rent drama
or some kind of like
bills drama in university
is just like a rite of passage.
I feel like everyone's
had at least one person
that they've been living with
(Connor laughs)
who has just been like the
most difficult dickhead
to fuckin' get any kind of money out of.
- I know, I know.
I just feel bad 'cause I feel
like I'm better than that.
- Yeah, right.
- I don't do this.
I wake up in a cold sweat, I'm like,
"What's that the statute of
limitations of stealing?"
(all laughs)
You know what I mean?
I don't know, 'cause even
though it's a small amount,
as well, I felt bad, but I was like,
"You know what? No. Fuck them."
- Yeah, exactly.
But also, it's literally like that
good kid does one bad thing and is like,
"Oh, shit. Is the police gonna come?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
You know what I mean? (laughs)
- That's called karma, man.
- That's why,
litters once,
"Oh shit. Am I going to prison?"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
I don't know, I just never
did that, I don't know.
Yeah, it was very,
it was very validating
but it was also like,
"Fuck. Am I gonna go to jail?" (laughs)
- "What's the limit to stealing
before the cops get
called on me?" (laughs)
- It's like one week and I'm good, right?
I'm free? I'm free?
- Have you ever stolen anything?
- No, no. Never. Never. (laughs)
Even as a kid.
- Even like-
- "Hello, this is "Trash
Taste" criminal records."
(all laugh)
- Yeah, me neither.
- Yeah, guys what's the most
illegal thing you've done?
Yeah, me neither.
- Well, okay.
You know how, in the UK
you can get, what was it?
There's like bakeries in the store
and you have to tell, on
the thing, what you got?
- Yeah.
- And I think one time I got a,
like four croissants and
I clicked what I thought was four,
I went through and then I came,
I went to the till and I paid.
Turned out, boys,
I chose the wrong croissants,
right? On the machine.
- Big sad.
- And it was actually
cheaper than what it was.
- Oh, damn.
- And I felt-
- You absolute criminal scum-
- I know, right?
I know, I know, so I left the store.
I got about like ten
seconds out of the store
and I looked at the
receipt and I was like,
"This is not, this is not the."
'Cause I actually got I
think the chocolate ones,
and I was like, "This is
not the chocolate ones.
This is 20p extra."
(Joey laughs)
And I went back and I was like, "Hi,
do I need to change,
like pay the difference?"
And the guy was like, "I don't care.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
It's like 20, I don't think they care."
(Garnt and Joey laugh) And
I was like, "Are you sure?
I don't mind paying.
I feel bad that I walked
out with 20 pence,
the wrong, uh, you're not
gonna call the cops, right?"
But he was like, "Dude
it's, what, no one cares."
- I've had that before, I did the,
you know when you're really, really young
and you do the accidental stealing?
- Yeah, true, true.
- The completely unaware stealing?
So I did that once,
I think I was like fuckin' I don't know,
five or six years old
and in Australia there's
like newspaper stores
where people go to buy
newspapers, magazines
and usually at the front cashier,
there's all these really
small, cheap candies
and chocolates and stuff like that
that kids can buy and whatnot.
And I specifically remember
there was one time I went,
'cause I think my dad had to
go buy a newspaper or something,
back when he was still buying newspapers.
And I picked out a candy.
I think it was like 10 cents or 20 cents
or something like that.
And I was like, "Dad, can I have this?"
And he was like, "Bugger off,
son. You're not having that."
And "We got sweets at home."
(Garnt laughs)
And I remember, I don't
know why, but that day,
I guess I was in a pissed
off mood or something,
I remember being really
angry that he didn't buy me
(Connor laughs)
this 10, 20 cent fuckin'
pissy little candy, right?
And I remember just being like, "Ah, man."
Just clenching my fists, being like,
"Goddamn it. Why? Goddamn
it father, why can't you"-
- I'm gonna steal right now.
- No, no. I was like-
- I'm about to steal. (laughs)
- No, I was just like, "God damn it."
Just clenching my fists really hard.
And then we walk out and
we're walking to the car
and I'm still pissed
off, clenching my fists
and then I kinda look
down at one of my fists
and I open my hand and-
- I've done that before.
- The candy's in my hand.
And I was just like,
slowly put it in my pocket.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- How did that get here?
- 'Cause I was like,
"Something feels weird
in my clenched fist."
(Garnt laughs)
And I was like, at that
moment, it was like,
fuckin' "Detroit: Become
Human" choice just popped up,
being like, "Do I put this in my pocket
or do I come out clean?" (laughs)
And I was just like, put it in my pocket.
"Imma save this for later."
- You know what I did try
and do one time and it.
Okay, so, you know how like corner stores,
they don't really have the super,
ultra-advanced labeling,
price labeling thing?
They just kinda have those
little cheap plastic,
paper stickers on the,
like the orange ones?
They would put like a pound or 50 pence,
and one time I thought,
I just had a giga-brain thought.
(Joey laughs)
I'm gonna swap 'em. I'm
gonna swap the labels.
Because I really want this
thing but I don't have enough.
I think I had like one pound
and it was one pound fifty,
I'm like, "Imma change the label."
And I was like, (deep breathing),
heart was fuckin' racing going
up to the stand, to the till,
I'm like, "Fuck. Fuck.
Play it cool. Play it cool.
Play it cool."
And he's scanning 'em and I'm like,
and then, as he's
scanning them I realized.
I'm like, "Wait, he's just scanned it.
And it doesn't fucking
matter what the label says
'cause it's a fucking barcode."
(all laugh)
And he was like, "Oh, that's
got the wrong label on it."
And I'm like, "Oh, does it? Does it?
Oh, shit. Oh, fuck. Fuck. Fuck."
- "Wow, I never noticed, thank
you for pointing that out."
- Meanwhile, my heart is like
(imitates heart pounding).
And I'm like, "Oh, shit." (deep breathing)
- I think the worst
thing I've ever done is
you know when, in England,
you know when they introduced
the self-service machines, right?
Which is the closest thing
I think England's gotten
to a trust system, right?
And on top of this, England,
within our lifetime,
England has added a plastic bag tax.
Which wasn't always there.
- No.
- Normally you could
take as many plastic bags
as you wanted.
Normally you could take as many
plastic bags as you wanted.
But I think, how many years ago?
Where they introduced the
5p tax in order to take
a plastic bag.
- Oh, like five years ago?
- Five, six years ago, I'd say.
- Yeah, like five, six years ago
and I remember this one time,
it was in a Tesco's or something
and I had like, I didn't
have my card on me,
because I just had gone out of the house,
so I just had change in my pocket.
And I came up to the till
and it was self-service
and it went up to the exact
change of my shopping, right?
But I hadn't bought the
plastic bag yet. (laughs)
So I was just like, "Do
I put everything back?"
- Nah, bro, if I was
working there, I'd be like,
"Bro, good on you for having
the perfect amount. Take it."
- So I was just like, "Do
I put everything back,
run back home, which is
only five minutes away
and come back with a tenner
or my card or something
to just buy this?
Or do I just press the "I
have paid for one bag"?
No, no, do I just press
the "Zero bag" option?
And I look around, I start
like fuckin' sweating,
'cause I'm just like,
"I'm a good Asian boy.
I've never broken the law in my life."
I'm just like, (inhales deeply)
check the security camera.
(Connor and Joey laugh)
Check the store clerk. Time fuckin' stops.
- Fuckin' put the hood up,
baseball cap on. I'm ready.
- Yeah, you know when you've
felt like you've got a fuckin'
spotlight on you?
And I'm just like,
"All right."
And then I just fuckin' leg it out.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- How dare he steal a 5 pence bag?
- And now that's on camera, so yes.
- Oh my god.
- I'm a criminal, guys.
- Absolutely criminal, Gigguk.
- I mean, to be fair, with that one,
I think I'd paid by card a bunch
and I'd forgotten to put the plastic bag
and they're literally right there.
And I'd paid by card and I had
no cash on me and I'm like,
"I am not getting my
card out for 5 pence."
- Oh yeah, of course.
- So I just take one.
They didn't give a fuck.
They never gave a fuck.
- No.
- Here Garnt's sweating and I'm
just next to him taking one.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- No because I'm pretty sure,
I've accidentally pressed
zero bags when I've taken one
or two bags so many times.
(Connor inhales sharply)
It's-
- No, Garnt. Say it isn't so!
- It's the conscious
choice, you know? (laughs)
(Joey laughs)
It's that I consciously made that choice.
- It's the confident press of the button.
- That's the difference
between manslaughter
and murder, Garnt.
(all laugh)
- No, I think that's why
the trust system works-
- It's conscious manslaughter. (laughs)
- I think that's why the
trust system works so well
here in Japan, 'cause I
don't know if we've mentioned
how they ID for alcohol
here, in konbinis right?
Which is, they never ask for ID
if you're buying alcohol
here in a supermarket
or a konbini here.
'Cause what happens is you take the beer
or whatever alcohol you want,
the clerk scans it and
then there's this button
that you have to press in Japan
that says, "I am over 18."
- Now-
- 20.
- No, it's over 20.
- Sorry, sorry, yeah it's over 20.
Now, in England, this wouldn't work.
Any fuckin' kid would come in and say,
"Yeah, I'm over the age of drinking."
Fuck, I remember, how
many kids had fake IDs
and just went fuckin' clubbing
back when I was underage, as well.
But here in Japan, I can imagine
just like this Japanese kid
just coming up and being like,
"I'm gonna cheat the system.
I'm gonna do what's
called a pro gamer move."
Gets up to the cashier and he just tries
to press the button and is just like,
"No. Can't do it. I can't do it."
- "I'm a child. I'm a child. I'm sorry."
- That is literally the equivalent of
going onto a porn website
and when it says like,
"You must be 18 years or
over," to enter the website.
And a Japanese kid being
like (sighs) "Shit."
- Like a Japanese kid is just
like, "Officer, arrest me now.
I've had bad thoughts."
- "I pressed yes. I was curious."
(Garnt laughs)
"Take me away."
- A Japanese kid's like, "Shit."
Turn on an anime. Full porn.
(all laugh)
Turns on TV.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's so pointless.
- I mean, as well, in
Japan, they have just
vending machines with beer.
Vending machines with cigarettes.
- I'd completely forgotten about that.
- Just on the street.
All right. Okay.
- It's not until recently
that the vending machines
that sell cigarettes finally
started to implement-
- Yeah you have to have a card, right?
- Like a card system to ID it because-
- But the alcohol ones don't.
- No the alcohol ones
don't. (Connor laughs)
- So a 14 year old will
be like, "What's Asahi?"
and then they just fuckin'
order and realize it's beer.
And there you go.
- There's definitely kids doing that.
100%.
- 100%
I did that. (laughs)
- I would too.
- But yeah.
- But yeah, first time I was
working up in the ski fields,
I was like 16 and outside
of where I was staying,
there was a vending machine
that was selling beer.
I was like, "Oh sweet, I
don't have to trek all the way
to the other side of
the road at the konbini,
I can just fuckin' go here."
- I'm sure the police don't
give a shit if you not show ID,
unless you're literally drunk as fuck
in the middle of the street or something.
- Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
- That's going very far.
- Exactly.
- They've got better things
to do. Like complain.
- Yeah. Complain about stepping too loud.
- ID a (speaks foreign
language) or something.
- Yeah, ID a (speaks foreign language).
(Connor and Garnt laugh)
- I don't know.
- But me being the
(speaks foreign language)
in the snow fields, I was like.
(all laugh)
- Bro, you fuckin'-
- They just come around the corner
and just bust me on the spot.
- This man fucking cracks it open,
the "Solid Snake" music starts playing.
Dun-dun-dun.
(Joey squeals)
(all laugh)
(Joey imitates siren)
- The (speaks foreign
language) opened a beer!
Oh my god.
- Have you guys ever stolen
your parents' credit cards
for anything when you were kids?
- No, no, no.
- No.
- My mom would find out
so fucking fast, bro.
(Garnt laughs)
My mom checks her credit
card like daily, for like,
there is absolutely no
way I could get away-
- Dude, I didn't even
know where my parents'-
- I never even wanted to.
- Credit card was.
- No, no.
- To me, money wasn't a
system where you could,
I never viewed it as a system
where you could game it.
I always thought of it as, I get money.
I spend the money that I get.
And I could earn money through things.
That was, I never even conceived,
I'm not saying this 'cause
I think I'm like a good,
I'm a good boy, I literally
never even conceived of the fact
that I could take money.
- That's not even a good boy thing.
That's just a boy thing. (laughs)
- Yeah, I just.
- That should be common sense.
- I just assumed the only way
I could get it was through
doing the tasks that I was allotted.
Maybe 'cause I played video games too much
and I thought task equals reward.
- Yeah, of course.
- I genuinely never even considered,
so I hear about these kids who steal their
parents' credit cards.
How is this so fuckin' normalized?
To me, it was never even an option.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Of like stealing my parents money.
- In my, when I hear that, I'm just like,
"Okay, you're like a nine
year old, 10 year old,
who just happened to get
their mom's credit card.
Like, how did you find that?"
- [Garnt] Yeah, I know.
- 'Cause if I was a nine
year old and I was like,
"Man I really wanna like throw
a Super Chat at this Vtuber."
I'm not gonna think like,
(Garnt laughs)
"Where's my mom's credit card?"
I'm not gonna start thinking,
"All right. Let's start the simulation.
Where could my mom's credit
card possibly be in this house?"
"Solid Snake" music starts playing.
I wouldn't even think about that, right?
- I would rather, I'd have more luck
trying to trick my parents
by convincing them."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think I probably have done
that before more than I have-
- "Mom, you don't understand.
They're my favorite Vtuber."
- Well, because if they,
they're the ones that put the details in
and they don't like it,
I'm like, "Well you did it.
You put it in. You
listened to my bullshit."
(Joey laughs)
"You let me do it." (laughs)
I'm too big-brained.
Kids, you're amateurs.
10 year olds nowadays
are too lazy, you know?
I should make guides on how to-
- You gotta fuckin' "Inception"
the idea into your parents.
- More kids need to be like Derren Brown,
the fuckin' big brain convincing.
(Joey laughs)
Don't steal. Convince other
people to steal for you.
(all laugh)
That's what you should do.
Isn't this like proxy
bullying or something?
The whole thing, oh my god, that was like,
"Don't bully. Get someone
else to bully for you."
- It's like social engineering.
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause it's so above me, as well.
I think I was just such a
straight edge kid, right?
'Cause I think even-
- Same, to be honest.
- Even when I was a kid,
I remember the first time
I'd ever gotten anything
from this thing called
the tooth fairy.
Now, I'd heard about this
thing called the tooth fairy
from all my kids, right?
From my friends at school.
- All your kids?
- Yeah, so not from all my kids.
From all my fellow kids at school
and they were saying, "Oh, yeah.
If your teeth come out,
you put it on your pillow.
You get a bit of money."
Someone once got pounds. Maybe two pounds.
I was like, "Damn.
That's a business
opportunity right there."
- Yeah, I was the wrong
kid to tell that to.
- Just going around
stealing people's teeth.
- I was like, "Damn."
So I remember the first
time I had one of my tooth
knocked out, I was so fuckin' excited.
I was like, "My time has come.
Finally, the tooth fairy will visit me."
(Joey laughs)
And so I go to sleep that day
and what do I find under my pillow?
Five fucking pounds.
- Shit.
- I'm just like, "Holy shit!
I'm fuckin' rolling in it, man."
But also, I was a good kid, right?
So I knew my parents
weren't that well off.
So I was like, "Mom, you know what I got?
I got five pounds. But you know what?
I don't need it. Treat
yourself Mom." (laughs)
- Aww.
- Wow!
- I didn't realize at the time,
I found out two years later,
I just gave the five
pounds my mom gave to me
back to my mom.
And I'm just like, "Mom! I can't believe
I've been swindled like this." (laughs)
- She probably thinks,
she's probably never been-
- Money laundering at its finest.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- To be fair,
is there any prouder moment as a parent
than if you kid did that?
- Yeah, right?
- That's literally like the
whole Bible tales that you hear.
- You literally Good
Samaritan-ed that shit.
- Yeah, I remember they
came into school and
they did this presentation one time.
'Cause, our school wasn't
like a Christian school
or anything, but we did
pray three times a day
and then every single story
had to be fuckin' Bible story.
So I thought that was
kinda sus, but anyway.
I remember this one story they told out,
just stuck out in my mind and
I hated this story so much.
I thought this was the
dumbest fucking story.
- (laughs) Okay.
- They'd be like, "What
do you want for Christmas?
You could have five pounds or a Bible."
And then it was like, "Everyone,
the first person chose the five pounds.
(Joey laughs)
They got given the five
pounds and they were happy.
The second person asked
for the five pounds.
And they got the five pounds
and they didn't want the Bible.
The third person, they chose the Bible.
And when they opened the Bible up,
there was 10 pounds in it."
And I was like, "What is
the moral of this story?
What is?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Even when I was a kid, I was like,
"Are you trying to tell me
that every Bible has a tenner in it?
Because I'm gonna go around and look."
And there was no tenners.
And I'm like, "Wait,
so what is the moral?"
Genuinely, now?
What is the moral of this story?
Even 10 year old me was
like, "This is dumb."
(Joey laughs)
"This is really dumb."
- It's like that's not how it was-
- And they're tryna be like,
"Choosing knowledge over money is more,"
I'm like, "Wait, wait,
wait. Hold up. Hold up."
- Is more valuable.
- I'm like, "Hold up.
Hold up. Price of the
bible's like three pound.
So wait, hold up? What are you?"
(Joey laughs)
I'm like, "We can't guarantee
there's always gonna be
money in the Bible."
You know?
- So technically,
if I get the Bible, I take the
tenner and I sell the bible
for three pounds-
- Exactly, you know.
- That's 13 pounds.
- I was just like, "This is dumb.
This is a dumb, dumb. Shame on you.
You could've, you're so lazy.
I know I'm a kid, but this is so."
And this annoyed the fuck out of me.
And they told this thing like three times
in my whole school life.
And every single time, I
used to get seethingly mad
when they would tell this story.
And no one else seemed
to be bothered by it,
they were like, "Yeah
that's a good moral."
I was like, "This is a dumb, dumb moral."
This is never a situation you would be,
who asks you which gift
do you want, you know?
And it's never gonna be
between money and a book.
It's always, "What do you
want for your birthday?"
It's not, "Oh which two do
you want? Money or this?"
It's like, maybe the money.
- Yeah, what is this choice option?
- Yeah, but it's never
a philosophical question
of which do I want, I'm just
gonna take the thing that
I want, this shouldn't be a fucking
a question of my moral standing.
(Joey laughs)
You're giving me a gift
for Christmas, fuck off.
- (laughs) It's like Christmas
is which one do you want,
the "Millionaire" music
just starts playing,
it's like (heavy breathing).
- [Connor] It really annoyed me.
- "Can I call a friend?"
- It's just the whole,
I really, really, really,
really, really despise
when they try and turn-
- That's really weird.
- When they try and turn
very unreligious situations
or philosophical situations
into philosophical situations.
That have no right to be.
I'm like, "I'm just tryna
buy my homie a present.
I wanna know what they want."
Genuinely. I'm tryna be a good friend.
If Garnt wants the five pounds,
that's what Garnt wants.
- Imma give him the five pounds.
- Who am I to preach that Garnt
wants to fuckin' Bible, bro?
He doesn't want that shit.
(Joey laughs)
Maybe he's not religious.
You know what I mean?
I'm not tryna save him. What is this shit?
- You want five pounds?
Are you sure about that?
(Garnt laughs)
I gotta Bible!
- And every year I got older
and they would tell this story,
I would get more annoyed by it,
the more I realized how
little sense it made.
And this whole, I don't know
if this is a common thing
or something that they
just told at my school,
but they would tell
this story all the time.
And I hated it.
- I mean, I went to a
Catholic high school and I've
never heard of that story.
- I don't know if it's
something that they made up
and this was like their
banger that they kept in,
like the person telling the story.
(Joey laughs)
- It was just-
- This is the story that
gets people to discover Christ.
(all laugh)
- It's like, "Oh, Lord!"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
"Oh, Lord!"
- "Oh, Lord, a tenner!"
(all laugh)
- It's like, "You're not
a Christian yet? Oh, just-
- [Connor] I remember one time.
- "Connor, tell him the Bible story.
Come on. Come on. Come on."
- And I remember one time, as well,
because they used to
tell my primary school
and I remember, 'cause this
is the one that really pissed me of.
I just remembered this right now.
Is that the headmaster of my high school,
'cause it was the primary school,
the elementary school, who told it twice.
Throughout the elementary school.
I remember this, 'cause I always hated it
so it always stood out.
I remember it, my head, my
prime, the sub headmaster came in
and he fucking came in and
he started talking about it.
And I'm like, "No. Don't
you dare tell this story."
(Joey laughs)
And he had the audacity to bring
in both the props, as well.
- Oh my God.
- And he couldn't just tell the story,
he had to ask the kids
which one they wanted.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And it backfired, 'cause
the first kid he asked
was from the same primary school as me,
so he knew the answer.
And so he asked, "Which one do you want,
the Bible or the five
pounds for Christmas?"
- And the kid was like, "Bible."
(Joey laughs) Immediately.
And he was like, "No. Have another go.
Which one do you really want?"
"Bible."
(all laugh)
And he had to be like, "Good answer.
That's the correct answer
'cause there's a tenner in there
to reward your faith."
And I'm like, "Fuck
off. No. Fuck, off, bro.
I hate this. This sucks. I hate this."
And this made me more not,
this made me despise religion even more.
From a young age.
(Joey laughs)
This is not the way to
get kids into religion.
- Exactly. There's better ways to do it.
It's literally just tricking them, right?
And just being like,
"Yeah this kinda untrue,
unrealistic thing, happens all the time.
Take the Bible."
- There's just so many
of these religious things
that when you actually
break them down into
real scenarios, just don't
work in a way that you're like,
"Just stop. Just stop."
I don't mind people's religion
and all that, of course,
- Of course, of course.
- I'm not against that but when they-
- There's better ways to
get them into it, right?
- Yeah, when they try and
teach these stories like this,
I'm like, just "No. Shut up."
- Exactly.
- I can't wait for a
fuckin' Jehovah's Witness
to knock on your door and you open it
and you just see the Bible
and a thousand yen in the other hand
and you're just like, "No." (laughs)
- Grab the Bible.
- Grab the Bible,
shut the door.
(all laugh)
It's like, "Oh, sweet." (laughs)
- It's like, "Just shake it,
shake it, shake the Bible."
(all laugh)
- Yeah, you just grab the
Bible just, "Here you go."
(all laugh)
- Just the dumbest thing.
Why did I tell this story, again?
I don't know why.
- I don't know.
- Anyone know why I told this story?
I can't fucking remember.
- I think we were just
talking about, sorry?
- [Meilyne] Morals.
- Morals.
- Ah, it's the stealing, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. (laughs)
So moral of the story-
- Moral of the story,
take the Bible, 'cause
there's a tenner in there.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah. Always take the Bible-
- All the time.
- If someone questions you.
- Every Bible you see has
a tenner in it somewhere.
- And in any other situation,
just take the fiver.
Unless you want to take the Bible.
- I don't need religion to
tell me not to be an asshole,
I'm already doing that, frankly.
I'm trying my best. You know?
(Joey laughs)
When the man in the taxi offered
me the money or the Bible,
I took the money.
(all laugh)
- (speaks in foreign language)
Just like, "Excuse me, sir. Bible?"
- I hope you all got that callback.
(all laugh)
- 4000 yen or the Bible?
- Yeah, he was like, "Do
you want reimbursement
or the Bible?" (laughs)
Is it was all a set up.
It was all a set up.
(all laugh)
- (laughs) What kills me is
what Christian out there,
who is already a Christian
doesn't already own a Bible?
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- Who out there who was posed
this question would be like,
"You know what? I was just
looking for a Bible, actually."
- "Oh, shit man."
- [Garnt] "Shit."
- "I needed a seventh copy
of the Bible in the house.
I'll take the tenner as
well, thank you very much."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Jesus Christ.
- This has been like one
of the weirdest tangents.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Starting off season two strong, I can see.
My god.
- (laughs) It always just annoyed me.
I'm still annoyed about it, to this day.
When I go back, if I ever go to school,
I'm not gonna give a shitty talk,
I'm gonna, I should do an
even worse one than that.
I'm gonna come up with the worst.
- You know what you should do,
you know what I'm gonna do?
If I ever have a kid, I'm gonna
tell that story to my kid.
- You should.
- But not put the tenner in the Bible.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- But like, "You're dumb.
There's one of these in
every single hotel room.
You coulda got one for free.
You're not a fuckin' hustler."
- (laughs) Shoulda taken the five.
(all laughs)
- So, how was this spread out
throughout your entire region, or?
- I don't know, well, you
know, I think it's because
the area where I grew up was,
everyone, every teacher
knew every other teacher
in the high school."
- I guess you did live-
- All the police people knew-
- In a small village.
- All the, you know?
Odds are that is that half of your
school would have,
all the teachers at the school
were people who went to the school.
And all the people who got jobs
were relatives of people
who worked in the school.
And it was all very tight-knit,
very, very tight-knit.
So I think all the stuff got passed down
and everything that they thought,
"Well, this is a good idea,"
just kept getting repeated and
yeah, everything-
- Probably some dude being
like, "I've gotta banger
story for you. (laughs)
Check this out."
- Yeah, stuff you did
in primary school somehow
the high school teacher
would tell you about.
You're like, "How did
you know I shit myself
in third grade?"
(Joey laughs)
"How did you know that?"
"Who told you there that?"
- Yeah, how do primary school
teachers still remember
every student that they've taught?
- This is the thing, the thing is
that this would be totally unrelated.
This would be a different
school, different teacher
and they would somehow
know the shit that you did
in primary school.
And you're like, "Stop talking
to each other about me.
Don't talk out of school.
Don't talk about me.
Talk about me in school.
Don't talk about me outside of school."
(Joey laughs)
- Oh.
- Oh, shit.
- Okay, it's back.
- "Trash Taste" malfunction.
(Garnt laughs)
Guys, we all shop online.
And we've seen that promo code field
taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free shopping tool online
that allows you to search
for coupons automatically
and applies the best one to your card.
Honey supports over 30,000 stores online.
Imagine it, you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites,
when you get to the checkout, ah!
The promo code field
drops down and taunts you.
What do I do?
Well, you simply click that Honey button
in the top right corner of your browser
and it automatically searches
through all the possible
coupon options available on the web.
And it automatically applies
the best one to your checkout,
if there is one.
And if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll just watch the prices drop.
I recently saved $20
on a new pair of shoes
and that's just nice.
That feels good.
Honey has found its
over 17,000,000 members
over $2,000,000,000 in savings.
If you don't already own Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and takes
a few seconds to install.
And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting us, the boys.
I use it myself and I've even
used it on stream before.
So, what are you doing?
Get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste,
that's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Back to the episode.
Completely unrelated, but
an hour after the FCCJ thing
we did, I got two emails
from, I don't even know
if they're students or teachers or what,
from my high school.
In Welsh.
Just from, saying, one
of the teachers misses me
or something.
- (laughs) What?
- And I was like, "What?"
- How does a teacher remember you?
- Oh, actually I mean, they remember,
it's a small school and also, I,
I think we've had like my brother
and my little brother went there,
so three generations of ours.
And I've also, I did talks there.
- You did talks?
- Oh, you went back to your school
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- To do talks.
- I did a talk there, which was terrible.
'Cause I didn't prepare at all,
I just went there and I was like,
"What do you want me to say?"
I don't know.
- Are you YouTuber?
- All you have to say is I'm a YouTuber
and every kid is just
like, "Tell me more."
- No, so-
- Yeah, tell me more.
- I'm immediately interested.
- We'll actually, actually, now
I have a frame of reference,
so I've done two talks now.
I've done one talk at my high school
for sixth form students,
which are like 17, maybe 18.
And I've done a talk at
my mom's primary school
for 10 year olds.
It was very different experience.
And I way, way, way enjoyed
talking to the 10 year olds
way more than I did the 17 year olds.
'Cause 17 year olds,
they're at that age
where they're way too
shy about everything.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they're starting
to get self-conscious.
They hate life. I mean I did.
- I mean, everyone remembers that age.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- And so, even though I've thought,
"Yeah, I'm a YouTuber, right?
This is a cool-ass job.
I'd be fuckin', I'd be
like "Yeah, this is sick."
I went out and they're like,
"All right so who's got any questions?"
Fuckin' no one had questions.
(Joey laughs)
I'm like, "Man, what's going on?"
I'm like, "Am I not cool?"
- "Is it me?"
- "Am I not cool?"
Is this not epic?
- "Are you not being
entertained right now?"
(all laughs)
"Are you not entertained?"
- What do I have to do, dab?
I'll dab.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
You want me to dab?
What am I gonna do?
- "I gotta TikTok."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- And then I was like,
and then, oh god, shut up.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
And then I think the
teacher felt bad for me
and he was like, "Oh, I have a question."
And I was like, "Oh,
fuck my life. This is so-
- "Do you know PewDiePie?" (laughs)
- You got the pity question.
- Yeah.
But then I think they started
asking some questions.
It was all right.
It was just terrible and I
had to talk in Welsh, as well,
and I'm not, and I can talk in Welsh
but I'm not as able to express
myself as much in Welsh.
- How do you say YouTuber in Welsh?
- Just YouTuber. YouTuber.
- Oh, okay. that's boring.
Sounds like Japanese.
- Same in Thai. (laughs)
- Oh, fair enough.
- I don't know, YouTube, YouTube,
it's kinda like a
slightly different accent.
- Yeah, (speaks in
foreign language) YouTube.
Just that's it. But-
- Fair enough.
- Yeah and it was all
right. It was just fine.
I shoulda prepared more.
But I also didn't know what to talk about.
I was like, "Just ask me shit?"
- I guess the 10 year olds
woulda been better, right,
'cause they were more curious.
- Bro, they were great.
They were fuckin' loving it.
They were, 'cause I also
was doing it over Zoom
and I had my streaming-
- Oh you did it Zoom?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because it was like three weeks ago.
- Oh, shit. Wow.
- Wait, you didn't tell me about this.
- Yeah, you didn't tell me about this.
- I was saving it for "Trash
Taste". (Garnt laughs)
- Oh, okay. Fuck. (laughs)
Wow, there you go.
- Thank God I remembered.
- We're getting the same
experience as you viewers.
- So I set up my streaming
stuff with the virtual webcam.
So basically, I had my
stream setup up to the Zoom,
and what I was doing was-
- Yeah, that's just my Phillips
Hues lights back there.
You know, I can control it.
- No, you were like, "So,
what do you think Twitch,
I mean, 10 year olds?"
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- So I had all the zooms
and the wide angles
and I was like fuckin' around with that
and doing all the sound effects
and doing all the memes sounds and stuff
while I was doing the
presentation for them
and answering their questions.
- You like these memes, kids? (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah. I was literally
doing live video editing
and these fucking kids
were losing it, bro.
It was so fun. It was so satisfy-
- Were you just in a private livestream,
you just did a private Twitch
stream, basically. (laughs)
- Yeah. Literally.
- Yeah. It was so fun.
These kids loved it, bro.
- Oh, I bet.
- They were like,
every time I did the
fucking wide camera angle
they fucking started
pissing themselves laughing.
It was so fun.
And (laughs)
and they also all watched anime.
- Oh, wow.
- Which was great.
- Yeah, I remember you
saying in the FCCJ interview,
that you were like, "What's
your favorite anime?"
And you said "Attack on Titan".
- Yeah.
- I assume you just said that
'cause you were just like,
"What's a popular anime every kid-"
- So these kids were 10 years old.
They should not be
watching "Attack on Titan".
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- They should not be watching.
- Shoulda said "JoJo" and see if-
- No, I don't think, no.
- How far the net has been casted.
- So I said "Attack on Titan"
and these kids all went like, "Yes!"
They were like, "Who's
you favorite character?"
I was like, "Captain Levi."
They were like, "Yes!"
(Joey laughs)
And I was like, "What
the fuck is goin' on?"
And they're like, "What's
your favorite sound effect?"
And I started playing with them and stuff.
They loved it. They were like, "Oh."
I was surprised 'cause normally
the one question you get
from kids is like "How much do you make?"
None of them asked that.
I was very, like "Wow. Nice
kids. Very respectful kids."
- Yeah, because at that
age, right, YouTube is still
kind of in the dreamscape, right?
It's not until you hit high
school where you're like,
"So is it worth not going to uni for?"
- Do 10 year olds care about
how much money people make?
- No.
- I don't think.
- Some do.
- I never cared at 10 years old.
- I dunno, it depends on the kid.
But they were really nice.
They asked, they were like,
"Oh, what age do you
recommend starting YouTube?"
And I was like, "That's a tough question."
'Cause at one point, I'd
recommend stay as far away
from the internet as
possible as long as you can.
But I'll also, on the other hand,
getting experience editing
is never a bad thing.
Getting good video
editing from like age 12
is just great experience.
I mean, just for life in general.
Being able to make
videos is a super useful,
very handy technique
that will come in useful,
I guarantee, in your life.
At some point you will wanna make a video.
- Yeah. Even in a corporate
job, it's useful as fuck.
- You will wanna make
a video at some point.
And being able to make a
video and not shit yourself
opening software is very useful.
- True, true.
- And I was saying, "It's
all just being able to learn
something's great."
It was great. These kids were really good.
I was like, "I," I sort of
felt like, I was kinda proud.
I was like, "These kids are
good. Good kids, these."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I was like, "They're askin'
the right questions."
- Good lads, these lads.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm like, "You gotta
a good set there, Mom."
They were like, "Did you like school?"
And I was like, "Of course I did.
Only when my mom told me
to." My mom was in the room.
- Oh, okay.
(all laugh)
- I was like, "Yeah, of course."
And they were like, "Oh,
did you like school?"
And I was like, "Of course I did.
That's what I told Mrs. Colquhoun.
But secretly, no I didn't."
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- So, this thing was it a Zoom call?
- Yeah.
- Or were, was it like a virtual classroom
or were they in a physical classroom?
- They were in a physical classroom.
I was on like a big screen.
- [Garnt] Okay. Right.
- And I could see them.
And then, at one point,
I tried to show them
my audio setup thing
and it unplugged and crashed my whole PC.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And I was like, I texted
my mom, I was like,
"Mom, I'm sorry, gimme five minutes.
Gotta reboot my whole PC."
It was pretty bad, but it was good fun.
They were really cute.
They were really nice.
- I wanna do that.
- That sounds really fun.
- I'm sure, ask-
- Where's-
- Ask your-
- Hey, Allambie Heights Primary School,
gimme the email.
- Hey, Baginton Mill,
come on. Come on. Come on.
I'm right there. I'm right there, man.
- I was just tellin' my
mom, I was telling my mom,
I was like, "Ah, sure." 'Cause
my mom really wanted to,
I don't know, maybe she wanted
the flags, I don't know.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, hardcore. Hardcore.
- I don't know why Mom wanted,
'cause they all knew I was a YouTuber
but my mom didn't want
to tell them who I was,
'cause all my stuff is not
appropriate for 10 year olds.
I was like, "Fair enough."
I mean, especially "Trash Taste" is not-
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, let's not show them "Trash Taste."
- Nevermind. Allambie Heights,
I take that back. (all laugh)
Maybe it's not a good idea for the kids
to be exposed to my content.
- Oh you can call someone
and talk about it,
they don't have to know your
YouTube channel, I guess.
- Maybe the sixth graders can watch,
but anyone below that, probably not.
- Baginton Mill, show
them the hentai episode.
(all laugh)
- Joey's like "Fuckin',
I went to a porn studio.
I went to Porn Land."
- Show them the episode d-link.
- Here's my favorite porno.
(all laugh)
- Perfect content.
- Oh, no, no.
- I'll send you the Patreon
version, it's all right.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, it was fine.
I mean, it was way more
fun than the high school.
'Cause the high school I just
stood there and I was like,
"What do you wanna know?"
And they were like, "Ah, nothing."
I'm like, "You're all
boring. You're all boring."
- It's like "We know what you do."
Yeah, because I guess at that age,
it's like you hear enough
about the behind the scenes of
YouTubers, right?
Because you kinda start to
explore further past the surface.
- But, I do feel that like one thing,
especially in a small
town where I grew up,
you're not told anything about
being able to do anything
outside of your small town.
You know, the most ambitious
thing you're told about doing
is leaving your town to go
to another university town
in the UK.
Like, the thought of being
able to go to a foreign country
and study was like never
even brought up to me.
It was never even suggested to me
that was a possibility.
No one in my school studied abroad.
That was not even mentioned.
And now I feel kinda cheated
that that was never mentioned to me.
'Cause I meet people who studied
in all of these countries
and that was just 'cause
their school was like,
"Oh, by the way, these
courses are available."
I'm like, "Why did no one tell me?"
This is my,
this is like, maybe it's my
teachers' fault, I don't know.
Someone should've told me
that this was an option
that I coulda done.
This is something that
there shoulda been more
options told to me.
And so I went into there and I was like,
"Listen, the teachers
are gonna tell you stuff.
Like what they're supposed to tell you.
But please, do your own
research and check for courses
that interest you, check
for international courses,
check for stuff that's
outside of what is being told
and fed to you.
Because there is so much more options
that are so interesting
and way more fitting for you.
Like somebody who hates engineering,
like myself, who did it,
was never really gonna
get an engineering job.
Maybe I would, I'd realize
within two, three years
I despise it and I would quit
and go do something else.
- That might of been like a
deadbeat job for you I reckon.
- Right. It woulda been
something I despised, right?
And that was just because I didn't,
there was no other
options presented to me.
And I almost feel like
the system was kind of,
failed, because it
didn't tell me anything.
I was just told these
are the courses I can do.
"Just choose.
Or go to McDonalds, see ya buddy."
- Yeah, and I feel like
a lot of people do just,
it's not a case of people
don't wanna do this,
it's just a case of people just
don't know that it's out there.
'Cause I had exactly the
same experience with you,
where the only reason I have a more
understanding about international culture
is because I come from an
international background
and an international family.
Because my family flew over from Thailand.
That's the only reason I knew,
but even with that background,
I had no idea how many different
paths I could've taken,
in terms of study abroad
or have different kind
of experiences like that.
- Yeah. If you speak fluent English,
you can go and study in any
English-speaking country.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And apply for an international student
and you'll probably get
accepted if you're not,
if you don't have like a
fuckin' criminal background.
You'll probably get accepted.
And if I'd have known that I
coulda just gone to America
and studied I'd have done that.
- Yeah.
- 100%.
I woulda done that.
- That's one of my
biggest life regrets, is
the fact that I got offered
to go study in Japan for two
months during high school.
And I said no, because I was too lazy.
And that's legit the biggest
fuckin' regret in my life.
- Same here. I think I always
had the same opportunity
to study abroad when I was in high school
and I just didn't take it,
'cause I'm like "Well, none
of my mates are taking it,
so why would I take it?"
- [Joey] Yeah! Exactly.
- And I'm just like, well that-
- It's like, "I'm gonna be away
from my friends and family for like
three months, I don't want that."
- Instead I went to another
shit hole Welsh town.
I'm kidding, it was all right.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
But I would've loved to
have explored, you know?
And done more stuff.
And if I knew that was an
option, I woulda gone for it.
So that's the main reason
why I went to the school,
to talk to these kids,
was 'cause I was like, "Tell
these kids." Sorry. (laughs)
- What the fuck was that?
- "Teach the kids."
(Joey laughs)
"Gotta teach the kids."
No, I thought, I'd let them
know and just say like,
"Listen, you can do shit." (laughs)
- Yeah, just do shit.
- You can literally do anything
you want, bro. (laughs)
- Don't let your dreams
be dreams. (laughs)
- So, hopefully, one
of those kids looked up
and did something and had fun.
Probably not, though, I mean.
(Joey laughs)
- I mean, 'cause even in university,
there would be like courses where
you'd have the opportunity
to study at one of
their sister universities
in another country.
And I remember, there were,
you can tell the kinda people
who were going to study abroad,
'cause they just seemed like
they were up for anything.
And I was just like, "Man."
I wish I had the balls that you had.
Back when I was in
university 'cause I feel like
that woulda been one of the
best experiences in my life.
Or just like a really valuable and,
a valuable piece of experience that
I just didn't get until
later in life, right?
'Cause I feel like,
part of your life after university,
and especially during your mid to late 30s
is that you kinda realize that life
just kinda stays the same
unless you actively search
for new experiences.
- [Connor] Yeah, exactly, that's it.
- And I didn't realize that until after
university life had ended,
that we were just really lucky,
as a kid, as a teenager,
whatever, to just,
every year you'd kind
of get a new experience.
But, once that period
of your life is over,
then you just have to
search for that yourself
and it's just not gonna come to you,
you gotta do that yourself.
And that's why I feel like a lotta people
who we, in the same area
who we grew up with,
they just didn't end up
staying in that same area.
Or they just,
you go back home and they
haven't changed much, right?
And that's just because
they haven't realized that
if they don't do something,
then nothing's ever gonna change
and some people are comfortable with that.
And that's completely fine.
But I think there are,
I've met enough people in my life who
have like this urge to do something new
and do something different
but don't even know where to get started.
- You should go for it.
- And I feel like, just go for it.
Just do you-
- You miss every shot
you don't take, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's like it.
- Just do something out
of your comfort zone.
- Yeah, at some point.
- Yeah, you don't need
an excuse to do anything.
- Yeah, just take a risk.
- I remember, one time, my friend went
and traveled abroad alone.
And I was like, "Wow. What the fuck?
You can do that?"
(Joey laughs)
"Just go somewhere for fun, alone?"
And I remember I thought, "Okay.
I'm kinda jealous that this guy
just had the balls to do that."
And now, I wouldn't mind doing that.
I'd do it.
I wouldn't, it's not preferable.
But I wouldn't mind doing it.
If I wanna go somewhere,
or you wanna do something,
you don't need an excuse to do it.
Just fuckin' go somewhere.
- Just do it.
- I always thought, I remember,
I was talking to a guy who had,
back in university,
he was talking about,
this was a guy in his 30s,
"Yeah, I used to work at this big company.
And then I just quit. And saved up.
And just traveled, for
like a year or two."
And I'm just like, "Wait.
I thought gap years were,
I thought you could do
that after your gap years.
That's what gap years were for."
And he's just like, "No,
I just did it because I just
needed change in my life."
And you're like, "Wait,
but what happens when you go back?
What, you have a career, right?"
I just couldn't comprehend
someone just doing
something out of
the life path that, you know,
the career path that I was taught."
- [Connor] You can do everything.
- It's like, yeah, the
moment you have your career,
it's like, "Why would you willingly
just end your career like that?"
- (laughs) Why would you just
quit your job like that? Ugh.
- Yeah.
- But, I mean, yeah. Fuck.
If I was in that position, I'd
probably do it too, you know?
And sometimes it does take that
kind of massive risk-taking
to realize that, "Oh,
maybe it's fuckin' worth it
to end your career.
Maybe that career wasn't worth it."
- I'm gonna end my career.
- Be a YouTuber.
- Yeah, YouTubers be like.
- Just be a YouTuber.
- YouTubers be like.
(all laugh)
- I'm just gonna end my career.
- I'm just gonna end my
career. Go on a trip.
- Yeah, but I feel like
especially this goes to most
high schoolers, because I feel like that's
the point in your life where
you have the most opportunity
to do something crazy with your life.
Not even something crazy,
just something outta your comfort zone.
Something that can increase
your perspective of
what happens in the world.
- Just try some shit out,
if it doesn't work out,
try some different shit, until it clicks.
- Yeah, if you're about to go
to university at some point,
and you might be looking
for courses or whatever,
dude, look around for international stuff,
whatever, there's tons out there.
- Anything that interests you.
- It'll be fun as fuck.
- Yeah. Trust me.
I remember, the biggest
adventure I'd gone on
is just moving cities to
go to my university town
and in England, every
city's kind of the same.
You get the same kinda experience,
you get freshers week,
you go drink a fuckton,
it's the same, (laughs) it
was like the same experience
no matter what university
I would've gone to.
And I wish I studied abroad.
I wish I'd done something new.
And I feel like,
after I quit to become a YouTuber,
I was gaining back the
years that I could've had
if I'd just gone out of my
comfort zone earlier in my life.
- Yeah, I've definitely been doing that,
since I've gotten so many
opportunities doing this job,
I feel like I'm just
playing a catch-up game,
I'm taking literally every thing
that comes to my doorstep now,
because I didn't take any
of that shit, back then.
- Yeah. Same, same.
- So and now I regret it.
Being like, "Oh, fuck.
Why was I so lazy and
dumb to not take these,
now that I look at it,
amazing fuckin' opportunities?"
Now I know that, everything
that comes to me,
even if it seems dumb or
pointless or whatever,
I'm just gonna fuckin' take it.
- Yeah, I mean.
I let "League of Legends"
ruin my life so I'm just,
I put far too many hours
into "League of Legends"
and I'm like, "I want
something from them."
- It's like, you know what,
I'm gonna try something else,
"Apex Legends".
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I'm gonna, it's like I
quit "League of Legends",
I might try happiness
for once, I don't know.
(Joey laughs)
See how it works out for
me, you know? (laughs)
- See which one I prefer.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I wanna see if it's for me, you know?
Gonna see if being happy works out for me.
- This thing called
happiness, what is that?
- What is this?
- "League" players be like. (laughs)
(all laugh)
- "I've heard about that before."
- Oh my god, I hate "League of Legends".
(all laugh)
I was so, I've never
felt more empowered than
leaving "League of Legends".
I feel like, "Wow. I have
more time for shit now.
Look at that. Look at that."
(Joey laughs)
- I feel like that,
I haven't touched a gacha game in a while-
- [Connor] Good for you,
Garnt. Good for you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, the only reason I
haven't is because I filled
that time with learning Japanese.
And I'm just like, "Well."
- The glow-up.
- If I'm gonna have time
wasted doing something everyday
then I might as well
do it productively and-
- I think that's not a waste then, Garnt.
- Yeah. Exactly. (laughs)
- So, it's not a time waste.
- Wow, that is like-
- Or, I should say, time sink.
- There you go.
- 'Cause learning a language
is definitely a time sink.
- "League of Legends"
is not a hour time sink.
It's like a four hour time sink.
(Joey laughs)
Minimum.
And then you get angry after it.
At least with Japanese,
you're frustrated after it.
You're not angry.
- You're optimizing
adulthood right now, Garnt.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- You know who else loves
taking opportunities and risks?
Our patrons. (laughs)
I'm just, I don't know. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
That's a wild accusation, but. (laughs)
I'm sorry if you're a
non-risk taker patron, but.
- That was like a segue
that just veered off
and crashed man. (laughs)
- [Connor] You tried, Joey. You tried.
- An attempt was made.
- Yeah.
Yeah, an attempt was made. That's right.
- As usual, look at these lovely patrons
who are now funding this new studio.
We literally, our patrons
are now funding this studio,
thank you very much for
letting us move to a place with
adequate space.
- Adequate spwace. (laughs)
- It has been an extremely,
extremely expensive move,
but you guys have made it possible and
we've got all the new equipment.
- Hell yeah.
- And it all looks good
and we think the quality
shows for itself.
- Absolutely.
- I think it looks bangin'.
Really fuckin' good.
- Yeah, we literally could
not do this without you guys,
and I know we've said this
previous episodes where
we didn't expect "Trash Taste"
to be as popular as it was
but yeah, I mean,
we hope the results.
Ugh. I just can't speak today.
- We hope that, we hope
you enjoy the results
because this was all thanks to you, guys.
- Thank you guys.
- We hope the result show,
is what I was trying to say.
- I think we're all
slightly tired boys today.
This has been a calm
episode of "Trash Taste".
- Definitely.
- Has it?
I feel like we've talked
about a lot this episode.
- Have we? I don't know. Maybe we have.
- We've gone on many tangents.
- Maybe. Maybe. I dunno.
- We just came back from a month break
so we're slowly gonna warm up.
But yeah if you wanna support the show,
then make sure to go over to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit
and if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But, yeah.
- Yeah, that's pretty much everything.
- Thanks for joining.
- Yeah. Hope you've
enjoyed the first episode
of "Trash Taste" season two.
And we'll see you guys next time.
- What a nice studio.
- Bye!
- Look at this. Look at us.
- Look at us. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
(mellow music)
(mellow music continues)